to read here this morning for you before
starting the meeting um then we'll be
doing the pledge and then we'll be
opening the hearing on HB
87 regards to this meeting members here
in the room please mute your devices and
turn off the sound to avoid feedback
consider turning off video if you intend
to use the keyboard for taking notes for
good sound quality it is important for
members to speak clearly with some
volume soft voices may be heard but hard
to understand and the microphones in
room pickup sound very well be careful
about side conversations uh the
committee room computer will be muted at
the lunch break we will be having a
lunch break giving the agenda today um
and we will need representative ter
roian or representative uh Ross to mute
and unmute us as they're by the master
controls um the pre-registration
information for the entire day is
printed out through 30 minutes prior to
the first hearing I have it with me here
right now um you can still speak if you
you missed the deadline but your name
will not be called out if you want to
speak if you want to speak after all
pre-registered speakers have gone we
will be asking for anybody else who
wants to speak and you would raise your
hand in the zoom meeting format and be
recognized in regards to this actual
meeting as chair of the house election
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's eerc order number 12 pursuant
to executive order 20204 this public
body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today February 5th an executive session
may be held on any Bill referred to the
committee please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legis
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
device meeting platform that we're using
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform itself or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules RSA 91a and anyone who
has a problem with accessing this
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS
ledge. state. n. Us in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
and we are notified the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled all votes in
this meeting will be taken by roll call
vote and we start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance when each member
states their presence if you are
attending remotely please also State
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this this meeting which is
required under the right to no law um
actually before taking the role let's do
the pledge and then we'll be the form of
business thank you everybody I pledge
Nation
andice thank you
everybody clerk call the role for
attendance thank you
representative berser on uh I am
president I'm calling in remotely from
my home office and there is no one in
the room with
me you representative Barry I present
representative
Cody yes I'm I'm here at home and no one
is here other than
myself representative
graus I'm home no one else with me I am
present thank you good
morning
chairman representative gr
pres representative
Hamlet good morning I'm present and I'm
in my home and my son is in another
Hammer he just signing on there she is
yeah I'm
here
sorry
I'm present in my house and I have a cat
in another
room that I love the cat play
representative Hayward here
representative
Lane I am present at my home I'm alone
in my home
office representative McDonald pres
representative Mooney here
representative
Mirad representative mad's here by phone
himself yes mad can you hear me star
six on your
phone I can't hear you I can hear you
I'm not sure oh oh thank you for
indulging me Madam chair I'm sorry for
the inconvenience I'm present and
alone thank you so star six will mute
you as well as unmute you and star n
hand thank you very
kindly representative
O'Brien representative quy here
representative
Sandler okay let me move on uh repr
Roan representative Ward here at home
two family members in the house and a
around and I'm here okay all right thank
you all right the first item on our
agenda this morning is HB
87 this is relative to the definition of
electioneering and we have the prime
sponsor with us this morning to speak
us if somebody
can Elevate representative pusk
to on his
way he's in that limbo land there we go
I am
present good morning representative
welcome to speak on
hb7 okay I just everything restarted
okay here I am uh good morning uh Madam
chair uh and members of this auspicious
committee I noticed there's quite a few
of my friends
I have known for quite a long time on
this committee but anyway let me proceed
uh House Bill 87 relative to the
definition of
electioneering it is actually quite
simple it's it wants to remove the
clothing uh part of
electioneering the reason is I went to
the
polls
uh it wasn't even I don't even know if
it was a federal election or town
election I had a white hat one which
said something uh to the effect uh of
make America great and it had American
flag on it
um and I was asked to remove it by the
moderator uh that I believe infringed
Upon My First Amendment
rights this is a First Amendment issue
to
me uh so I came up to this bill because
I looked up some information and I found
out that the US versus Minnesota
decision of the US Supreme Court on 614
of
2018 by a 7-2 decision remove the
clothing uh PR prohibition from the
Minnesota
statutes uh justice Roberts wrote
Minnesota had failed to articulate some
sensible basis for distinguishing what
may come in from what may stay out that
was one of
the uh findings that I found uh doing
some
research and I'm going to keep this
short and simple and I'm going to close
with another chief justice Roberts quote
he wrote quote a rule whose Fair
endorsement requires an election judge
to maintain a mental index of the
platforms and positions of every
candidate and party on the ballot is not
responsible and thank you madam chair
for letting me bring this forward and uh
if I can answer questions I will if I
can't I am not a legal scholar in the
election law Arena thank you m Madam
chair thank you representative do any
members in the Pres in the room have any
representative representative C Brian
please thank you madam chair
representative pusin I I have a question
about the Minnesota law that youve
referenced is it possible that that law
was more vague than our law is and that
could be the issue they were they were
uh addressing specifically rather than
what we have here in New
Hampshire uh it potentially is a little
bit different when I came to write the
LSR I asked uh OSS to research the US
versus Minnesota decision and come up
with uh the verbage to change our uh RSA
and this is what they came up with based
upon that decision have that one I saw
that
one thank you further questions from
people in the room questions from
committee
members representative
Bergeron thank you Madame chairman uh
representative just a question I a quick
one I hope I understand uh the reasoning
for you're introducing this bill based
on your experience um however do you
think it would be appropriate for
representatives of candidates and
campaigns to dress up in a lot of uh
campaign promotional clothing and then
stand around inside the polling place
for uh an extended period of time uh
just just in in an effort to bring
campaign slogans into the polling
place uh thank you for the question
representative uh this does
not address the pole workers this only
address people who are walking in to
vote or walking out to vote it does has
nothing to do with the folks standing
outside uh waving signs or people and
and typically it pro uh people are
prohibited from standing around inside
the polls by the moderator and the
moderator's assistance so um if I wore a
T-shirt and I went in to vote
uh that would be under this legal but if
I was standing around talking for a half
hour in in an observation area I this
would not uh would not be
uh uh this under this RSA I would be
asked to leave and it would be
justified thank you representative thank
you other members of the committee who
questions
I'm not seeing any up representative K
Brian thank you madam
chair um M representative pus said could
it possibly be interpreted that PO
workers could wear these items if this
bill
any
could such things
good I I don't believe that pole workers
are uh in this it states people who are
going into to
vote uh and pole workers would still be
prohibited uh from uh wearing political
clothing as well as the folks that are
standing
outside
uh and actually in section 7 line
16-9
uh it says that basically is prohibited
with no electioneering caror established
outside the polling place by the
moderator which means uh the entry way
has to be free the inside of the polling
area would still remain free of any
political except for the people who are
going to vote this this this bill is
only for
voters has nothing to do with the people
working the polls or watching the
polls um and that's my tent is if I wore
a hat or if I wore a t-shirt or if a
friend of mine walked in with a with
feel the burn t-shirt or what whoever it
doesn't matter political party is
neutral on this whoever goes in as a
voter has does not give up their first
amendment rights when they walk in the
door thank you for your answer
representative
Cody
yes mam chair thank you representative
um so is what you're saying that if this
bill passes the only people that would
be prohibited from wearing uh clothing
with political slogans on it would be
pole workers am I am I understanding you
correctly okay well actually it's it's
kind of like the reverse the only people
who would be allowed to we our
voters expressing their first amendment
rights
can I have a followup Madam chair
representative Cody go ahead do you have
a citation for that Minnesota case that
you referenced earlier by any
chance
um I I Googled uh Minnesota US versus
Minnesota and I had a whole lot of
information uh it can be Googled uh like
I said I and I quoted Justice Roberts
from the uh from uh where I did that's
sir any other committee members with
questions representative
Ward uh thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question uh
could you point us to the lines in the
bill that refer only to that this
voters
okay uh thank thank you for the question
line8 on uh I guess it's page one
provided that a person eligible to vote
or registered to vote in the voting
district who is unable to remove or
cover clothing that's what we're getting
rid of and
they
and that's what I believe is the first
amendment issue is that they are re
restricting
voters uh from their first amendment
rights follow up Madam chair Senor for
go ahead thank you uh just to clarify so
you've struck the part that makes this
apply only to voters as I read it uh or
could you comment on whether this would
now apply to anyone in the polling place
um
this this is only meant voters it is not
meant for people working anywhere in or
around the polls uh and that's the way I
asked OS to uh write it and as far as I
can
understand it is restricting uh is
voters thank you thank you for your
answer representative
Hammer hi thank you for taking my call
um my comments here um representative is
can you define a worker at a polling
spot are they voters
too
um a worker at a polling spot it it is
my not
my uh job to define a worker in this
bill but if if you were to ask me which
you are who is a worker um a worker is
someone who is at the
polls not to
vote they are there for other reasons
they would be poll watching they would
be assisting the moderator or assistant
moderator or showing people
uh where to go to vote to write to to
sign in to register those would be the
workers a voter going into to vote or it
worker
thank go
ahead when um we have an election people
are ballot
inspectors and those are workers those
are also voters they live
in that
District can you explain more why those
people could not be
wearing or should could be wearing
political
clothing uh thank you representative I'm
glad you brought out that distinction
when you go to vote you do not give up
your first Amendment rights but when you
are okay you are done voting and you are
supposed to spend some time at the polls
working I believe you must remove the
political clothing if you weree a
t-shirt you have to go change your
clothing while you are working because
you have to be politically neutral while
you are working the polls
okay thank you thank you for your answer
members I'm not seeing any other
representative O'Brien thank you m
chair I I don't have a question but I do
have a comment because I found the case
that you were referring to
representative Tusk it's uh Minnesota
voters Alliance versus mansky and it was
argu on February 28th 2018 that helps
people to look it up 34 I haven't had
yet
um representative has a question
representative pus thank you
representative pus
um could you check with the uh
legislative services and just confirm
with them that this applies only to
voters and if not would you be willing
to amend the bill to make sure that this
applies to
owners I'm not sure that's legislative
Services job
but um the question representative pusk
is would you consider making an
amendment to this
bill um I I would rather not because it
is about as simple as I could make it
and it accomplishes the purpose and uh
the scope of what I asked o ask to do
thank
you any other questions from committee
members for representative
pusk I'm not seeing any hands or any
questions thank you very much
representative for being here this
morning also signed up to speak this
morning on this bill is a James Morgan
Mr Morgan if you're in attendance could
you raise your hand so I can recognize
you which requires me to be a little
more deaf with my um computer than I am
actually but we're trying to elevate you
um it looks like you have been elevated
if you
unmute um we will be all set thank you
good morning Mr Morgan good morning
Madame chairman thank you very much um
let me uh see if I can minimize this to
get to my thing good morning and thank
you madam chairwoman and Mr Vice
chairman honorable Democrats members of
uh honorable Democratic members and my
fellow Republicans for allowing me to
speak on this bill today my name is
James Morgan I'm an elected official in
Derry New Hampshire uh I am a counil
two-term town counselor I've been part
of the dairy Town Council for almost two
terms and an elected official in that
capacity I have worked in over a dozen
elections in New Hampshire including two
presidentials I have come to speak
against House Bill 87 from my
understanding the amendment to the
language within the statute only
addresses clothing or obvious parhelia
pertaining to a specific candidate party
or measure this mey mouth change would
not only create a new space for
political agitators but encourage it now
more than ever political tempers run hot
and emotions High I foresee this Chang
as a burden to our pole workers forcing
them to become Arbiters of a gutted RSA
during an election there is room within
the law for someone to express
themselves freely with limitation to
individuals questions or motions on the
ballot
this proposed amendment is
unnecessary New Hampshire voters
understand this law as it is now and
they respect it having interacted and
enforced this irsa during those 12
elections myself in Derry in my capacity
as an election official people are quite
understanding and very few and far
between when asked voters remove the Hat
cover the shirt remove the button they
do so because they understand that they
are there to have their voices heard in
The Ballot Box not in the line to
receive a ballot and not inside the
polling location the bill does not even
address poll Watchers who are also
voters I don't want to I don't want our
free and Fair New Hampshire elections
being called into question because of
undue influence of a poll worker's
outfit or a voter's choice of political
underinformative
Traditions I think we have all had
enough of grifters trying to call our
elections invalid in this state I do not
support turning our polling areas into
Billboards inciting tensions between
supporters inside such a meaningful
space either we take our elections
seriously or we invite potential chaos
New Hampshire could benefit from
election reform but reform should happen
collectively within our elected
officials who actually oversee our
if the argument for this change of the
bill is solely for the empowerment of
one's Free Speech the bill does not go
far enough and if the argument is we
want to copy Minnesota New Hampshire is
unique and doesn't need to do
so we should consider the optic this
provides are inanimate objects
projecting vote for me more important
than the content of what a candidate
believes or in or says when they speak
does the bill cheapen the honor and
importance of a polling location at a
time in our country when people are
questioning our own
Integrity the circus of campaigning does
not belong folded into the respectful
place a polling location should be when
we go inside to vote we are not
Democrats or Republicans we're Americans
we're Patriots we're friends we're
neighbors and together we're exercising
the most precious gift on Earth our
freedom to vote thank you house election
committee
Madam chairwoman for allowing me to
speak today thank you Mr Morgan do
members of the committee in the
Morgan I'm not seeing any do any members
of the committee attending remotely have
Morgan I'm not seeing any thank you very
much Mr Morgan for thank you madam
chairwoman us this
morning also signed up to speak on this
bill is Tina Gilford if you could raise
Tina I am attempting to elevate you I
been there you
are and I think you are with us and
conf hello can you hear me we can good
morning uh thank you very much um Madam
chairwoman uh I am Tina Guilford I am
the town moderator in Derry
um and I am speaking against this
bill uh the lack of
paraphernalia um keeps the sanctity of a
polling location and keeps anyone from
feeling that their vote is in any way
suppressed the most complaints that I
received from voters that had anything
to do with electioneering were that they
were on uncomfortable with candidates
yelling out comments to voters as they
pass the candidate
area um so this would be exacerbated
inside the polling place by any
candidates or their surrogates walking
in and out of the polling location or
standing in observation all decked out
for
hours um contrary to what um
representative pusk stated um that law
is not just for voters it's for anyone
in the polling place and while as a
moderator I can tell my poll workers and
instruct them that not only can they not
wear anything um I actually instructed
my poll workers that they couldn't roll
their eyes when in a primary somebody
selects a particular ballot because
that's not their
party
um this would be a very uncomfortable um
thing for most voters and the whole
point of Elections is for voters to feel
free
to ex exercise their unfettered right to
vote and they should do so in peace in a
contentious elections like the ones we
we just had um it would have required to
have more more pole workers and more of
a police presence than we already did um
just based on people's
behaviors and that would have just
driven up the price of the election even
more and I think most taxpayers are
tired of paying more for things
and while I understand that some voters
may love to show their support at the
end of the day everyone should be
comfortable when voting um in speaking
to the Minnesota law mentioned by rep
Tusk uh that law prohibited any and all
political verbage not just um tied to
who was on the
ballot um in prohibited campaign
material in New Hampshire includes the
following a vote for a candidate name or
party vote against a candidate name or
party to vote Yes on a question or vote
no on a question a picture of a
candidate a candidate's name or an
uncommon logo associated with a
candidate it's all tied to the
candidates that are on a particular
ballot um
so that's that was the issue with
commentary and that concludes my
testimony and I'm prepared for any
questions that anyone on behalf thank
you very much for joining us this
morning does anybody have any questions
for Miss Guilford representative Mooney
thank you madam moderator and thank you
m chair for recognizing me are you able
to hear me yes okay just for
clarification purposes as the moderator
can determine the standards and the
guidelines for the entire of your
workers
yes you know I I I can instruct them you
know not to wear ripped clothing dress
appropriate that kind of thing so I I
can do that for my pole workers but I
would not be able to do that for any
member of the public walking in
observation or a member of the press or
anything like that if I didn't have this
RSA to back me up thank you very much
thank you other questions from people in
room representative PR O Brien I looked
right at you and you didn't raise your
hand thank you madam
could you tell us uh and thank you for
coming today Miss Gilford could you tell
us uh how it has been when you in
general when you ask people to remove
the political attire that they're
wearing how reaction to them youever had
people that are um most of them are uh
very apologetic uh some people don't
realize um that it's actually a rule um
you have to remember sadly a lot of
Voters only vote once or twice every
four years um you know they don't come
out for elections on the regular uh so
um I I don't really get a lot of push
back um in all the elections I've worked
and I've worked probably about 15
elections or so um I've had one voter
give me push back um about his hat um
I've asked we've had had to ask voters
to go in the restroom and turn their um
t-shirts inside out and and none of them
have said oh no I'm absolutely not doing
that um they're all apologetic I've had
voters put pieces of tape masking tape
over something so that they can come in
and vote um so most people definitely
understand thank you questions from
remotely I'm not seeing any thank you
Miss Guilford for your testimony I also
have signed up to speak Teresa
basum if she's still online if she could
hand Miss basam welcome um I knowe that
you signed up to talk for 15 minutes we
do not have 15 minutes I apologize for
that um we are behind in part due to my
late start and in part due to the fact
that this bill has generated a lot more
testimony than I thought so if you could
join us and uh let us know your position
on the bill and anything new that the
committee has not heard this morning
welcome and if you could unmute I think
I have unmuted you so you should there
you go I think we're with you now
morning all right good good morning good
morning Madam chair and representatives
and members of the public my name is
Teresa basam and I am grateful for the
opportunity to speak today in favor of
House Bill 87 I don't need 15 minutes I
didn't know what put down for amount of
apologize I have also worked the polls
I've worked the polls as a ballot clerk
for more than a decade three four
presidential
elections multiple times and only this
year has the term electioneering come to
create so
much fur if you will and I actually
spoke to my state representative Alan
berstein and asked him to get this thing
changed
because this term electioneering which
the dictionary States as an activity of
trying to persuade excuse me Cambridge
English dictionary defines as the
activity of trying to persuade people to
vote for a particular political party
according to the American Heritage
dictionary electioneering is the work or
activity for a candidate or political
party these definitions indicate that
the election earing is active or an
activity such as door knocking working
phone Banks sending out hand flyers or
holding signs and waving and calling out
to passers by but only recently has the
issue of clothing such as um t-shirts
sweatshirts hats or buttons face masks
become a u course for where the
moderator or even our state our state uh
ag office today uh not today excuse me
during this last election um vot weighed
in on
what is or is not approved at an office
excuse me at a voting place I'm sorry
I'm
nervous um when I was working as the
deputy town clerk this past year for
this election Maga was considered a nogo
but BLM was okay and we all know that
that was as significant for a party one
party over the other as magot is I'm
asking that rather than Muddy Waters and
frustrate voters who 99% of the time
just want to get in and out that you
leave clothing and buttons off the list
and clarify election earing as an
activity in which a person or person's
engage in by verbally speaking or
physically handing out information to a
prospective voter that seeks to persuade
how that person will vote I don't
see any reason we need to make this more
complicated than it needs to be poll
workers by definition have to be neutral
and that includes ballot clerks or um
moderators assistant moderators people
guiding somebody as to where to go to
vote but the person standing in line to
vote should not be prohibited from
wearing articles of clothing that
they've purchased that yes may speak of
a candidate but to me it's no more
offensive or um uncomfortable than
seeing somebody come through with a
skeleton and crossbow
or some excuse me some other religious
or political
or save the whales or anything like that
we can you can take freedom of speech
and try and squish it as much as you
want there's always somebody who is
going to be offended by something let's
get beyond that and let
people be free to speak how they wish to
speak without stepping on toes and
letting people do what they just came to
do thank you thank you does anybody in
the committee room have any questions
representative Ross um yes thank you for
your testimony I didn't catch what town
you are from
um sorry I'm I'm from Nottingham
Nottingham um and you said that there
was an issue I'm assuming in Nottingham
um where BLM material was allowed but
magga material was not can you elaborate
on that well it was I'm not saying
specifically in Nottingham I was on on
because I worked as the deputy town
clerk during the election this
year I was on a zoom call with our ag
office and somebody asked the question
was BLM considered electioneering and
and I don't remember who it was but
somebody at the AG office said no BLM is
okay Maga is not because it's it's
specific to a candidate and I disagree
with that
totally thank you further questions from
committee members in the
room seeing none committee members
questions I'm not seeing any thank you
very much Miss basum for joining us this
morning you did great you didn't need to
be nervous so thank you for joining
thank you uh Deputy scanland from the
Secretary of State's office is with us
also uh to speak to the
committee
um thank you madam chair I'm David
scanland deputy secretary of state um
here I i' just like to say on this bill
that uh that we believe that the area
inside the polling place and especially
inside the rail should be a politically
neutral place where a voter can go and
exercise their right to uh vote their
choices on the ballot uh without having
campaigns follow them into the you know
into the same
location specific to House Bill 87 I
don't believe that the
the amendment uh to the law actually
does what the sponsors think it will do
if you look at line two uh the
definition of electioneering is there it
says electioneering means visibly
displaying or audibly disseminating
information that a reasonable person
would believe explicitly advocates for
or against any candidate political party
or measure being voted I think that
language would apply to political
clothing
uh whether uh that language is contained
starting on Section Five I'm sorry line
five of the bill or not that's that that
sentence simply starts by saying
electioneering includes but is not
limited to so I think just by removing
that language uh you are not saying that
it is okay to wear political clothing uh
inside the the polling place I think
that there would have to be affirmative
language specifically permitting that
for that to happen uh my recollection is
that this language that is uh being
struck uh in the bill was added to
actually help the moderators show a
voter wearing political clothing that
this is not permitted in the polling
place they could actually point to the
statute where it said that and so in
that regard it was a tool to help the
moderator uh let a voter clearly
understand that that was not permissible
so uh with that Madam chair I'd be happy
to answer any questions any questions
for committee
members any questions from committee
members attending
remotely I'm not seeing any thank you
Deputy scalan for attending thank you is
there any other member uh in attendance
that electronically we there is no
public person in the room who would like
to comment on HB 87 raise your
hand I'm not seeing any I'm going to
close the public hearing on HB 87 and
I'm going to open the public hearing on
HB
127 uh the prime sponsor of the bill
Norm silver is in attendance I thought I
just had you um I have found you
representative
silver and you should be with us if you
can unmute
welcome
ma have I got him up there
representative
silver there um I yes I'm here thank you
good morning representative silver good
morning thank you madam chair members of
the committee uh having been convinced
uh with an by an extensive conversation
with representatives of the Department
of Transportation that this proposed
bill is not needed at this time I
respectfully request that the committee
itl it thank you very much anybody have
any questions for representative
electronically I'm not seeing any
representative silver I'm sure the
committee will do everything it can in
its power to rean your request thank you
very much I was very nervous about
making his presentation
also okay thank you um also in
attendance is repres is um Mr doin from
do who has signed up to speak and I'm
going to ask him to raise his hand if he
wants to speak um he is I I want to make
sure he understands that the bill has
essentially been introduced in the most
minimal way
possible and we are being asked to itl
toins yeah I just simply just want to
confirm that yes representative um had
spoken with the Department uh just for
the record my name is Caleb Dobbins I'm
the state maintenance engineer for the
Department um thank you madam chair
members of the committee for hearing um
and yes we are in support of the itl um
that the representative has just
suggested thank you very much any
doin I'm seeing none are there any
attendees present who would like to
speak to this
bill I'm not seeing anybody raising
their hand I'm going to close the public
hearing on H B
1227 next on our agenda this morning is
HB 483 all right we're almost back on
track which certainly made some progress
um HB 43 is in regards to the
prohibition of certain political
advertisement um the sponsor is
representative infantine are you present
representative infantine if you can
please
Dam do you see him
anywhere I see a Galaxy
um I guess that's a phone designation I
don't know a Galaxy s20 Fe 5G has the
hand up I don't um know if that's
representative inventin or not I just
promoted it to panelist on the off
chance it might be okay um hope you're
right whoever you are Galaxy s20 f5g you
have just been promoted and unmuted keep
in mind no idea who you are and I have
the mute button at my fingertip welcome
this is representative infantine I'm
sorry I had to join by the telephone
excellent thank you good morning good
morning I will be extremely brief uh I
spent my first term uh in the election
law um so I have fond memories
unfortunately I sat or fortunately or
unfortunately I sat cross from
representative Ray Buckley at the time
and I watched him manipulate some of our
laws over the years and I don't like the
political advertising that goes on uh
both sides do it it's inappropriate and
citizenry doesn't like it and I'd like
us to start making some changes I have
emailed each one of you members a
advertisement from the Senate District
race and you know it just goes beyond
the pale here here criticizing people
for opposing things when they've never
been elected uh we're saying that your
friends are opposed to something and
trying to say that you actually will do
the same thing uh and I know every time
we go to the Attorney General's office
he well it's free speech it's political
speech we can say it uh I know this
doesn't have uh much of a chance in your
committee but I wanted to make the point
that we have to start doing something
about um
the way that both parties are putting
out mailings and literature when there
really it goes beyond Hal truths and
untruths and I'd appreciate if you would
uh make a stand and do something about
these things especially when someone has
never voted
before uh or been elected before and I
will be brief because I know you have a
long day Madam chairman thank you very
much thank you very much representative
does anybody in the committee room have
any questions for the
representative I'm seeing none does do
any committee members attending
electronically
have questions for representative
infantine I'm seeing none thank you
very this morning also signed up to
speak on this bill is Scott
spradling um you have been promoted so
if you unmute yourself you should be
with us committee members you have
received written material from Mr
spradling so welcome this morning Mr
spradling to add to the written material
that you have sent to us good morning
Madam chair and uh can everyone hear me
okay yes you're fine perfect thank you
very much uh it's nice to see all of you
happy Friday again my name is Scott
spradling I'm the government Affairs
representative for the New Hampshire
Association of broadcasters this is a
nonprofit group that since 1954 has
represented the TV and radio stations
located throughout our great state we
actually represent 98% of those who are
currently broadcasting news and
entertainment uh on the TV and radio
Airwaves throughout our state um I
completely uh respect and appreciate uh
representative infantine desire to uh
keep them honest if you will which is
what I quoted in um the the letter that
I submitted from uh Tracy Caruso who's
the executive director um I think one of
the challenges that we have here with
this conversation is that there is a
third rail at least when it comes to
broadcasters rules rights regulations
and oversight we are regulated by the
Federal Communications Commission and
when it comes to political advertising
whether it's for federal or state
candidates on TV or on radio the rules
are very strict uh and and they're
they're from our perspective they're
very clear that um if unless there is
something that is defamatory and action
needs to be taken on behalf of the other
campaign because there is something that
is absolutely um breaking the law in
terms of claims of the ads that they are
protected under Free Speech uh the
representative commented having been on
Election law committee before and all of
you are very experienced with this you
would completely understand that this is
a challenging balance of allowing people
to express themselves versus trying to
referee and make sure that the claims
made are truthful and accurate um I
would just simply say that um from from
the perspective of this particular Bill
we would recommend that you uh find this
inexpedient to to legislate based on
both the Constitutional violation and
the very difficult and challenging route
by which you would have to
set up a review process and uh some kind
of Statewide practical um um
investigatory process that might also
run a foul of what the FCC rules are for
broadcast I I understand that the
representative brought forward a um an
example that was a mailer um so I and I
understand that the printed documents
and things that are mailed out may have
a different set of rules but at least
from the broadcasting perspective uh we
would respectfully ask that the comp
applications that uh prevent any
practical application and the First
Amendment violations would just make
this um
uh an inexpedient bill so we would
respectfully ask that you vote itl thank
you thank you Mr spradling do any
committee members have any questions for
Mr
scrin representative Ross thank you want
constituent thank you
sir
any questions seeing none do any of our
question I'm not seeing any thank you Mr
spradling for joining us this morning
thank
you seeing is there anybody else in
attendance who would like to speak to
483 please raise your
hand on the zoom platform or hit star
whatever the magic number is to unmute
your
yourself I'm not seeing anything so I'm
going to close the public hearing on
483 the next item on our agenda this
morning is House Bill
263 263 is relative to campaign Finance
reform um the sponsors of that bill are
representative Sweeney representative
Alexander and representative Barry um I
am taking it that representative Sweeny
will be repes will be introducing this
bill welcome representative
Sweeny thank you madam chair and members
of the health elction law committee uh I
am proud to introduce Health Bill 263
relativity campaign Finance reform uh
the goal of this legislation is to
streamline our existing practices remove
barriers to entry for new candidates for
office and decrease confusion
surrounding candidate filings and update
our state's campaign Finance laws to
ensure that all candidates whether they
are running for the first time or the
40th time can navigate and understand
the system that governs campaign Finance
in New Hampshire currently New Hampshire
law allows candidates to agree to a
voluntary
expenditure the incentive provided under
current law to voluntarily limit
campaign expenditures is an increase in
the amount of money inid can raiseed per
donor per election period there are
three current periods of time that are
created via our current campaign Finance
structure there's the exploratory phase
before candidate filing the primary
election phase that runs from the day a
candidate files for office to the state
primary election and the general
election phase that runs from the day
after the primary to the state general
election if a candidate agrees to the
volunt to voluntarily limit their
expenditures they are limited According
to which office they are seeking as to
what they can spend but can raise $5,000
from a single Source in each period
totaling $155,000 over the course of the
entire cycle they can raise more per
Doner but they can spend less overall in
the campaign the amounts are written
into statute and do not increase cycle
to cycle to reflect the increased cost
of campaigns or operations as a
candidate if a candidate does not agree
to voluntarily limit their expenditures
they can spend as much as they like on
the effort but can only raise $1,000 in
theice primary and the $1,000 in the
general election since they cannot agree
or disagree to the expenditure limit
before they file their candidacy they
can raise $5,000 in the exploratory Cas
as a result candidates who don't agree
to the voluntary expenditure limit are
CA at raising $7,000 per donor per
complete 2-year cycle this is referred
to as the 5,000 plus 1,000 plus
1,000 most candidates for office do not
agree to the voluntary expenditure limit
thus most candidates fall under this
$7,000 per cycle per Dono limit the bill
before the committee today removes the
voluntary expenditure limit and the
exploratory phase from existing state
law and changes the limits per election
to $3,500 per donor this would maintain
the $7,000 per donor per cycle limit
that currently exists for those
candidates who do not voluntarily limit
their expenditures this move would
reduce the candidate filing form by
about a
as the last column on the state filing
paperwork regarding the voluntary
expenditure limit would no longer be
necessary this would also streamline
campaign Finance report by only having
two periods of time the primary and the
general election according to our
purposes the primary phase would begin
when a candidate starts running for
office and the threshold to file with
the Secretary of State's office would
remain unchanged at $500 raised or spent
per candidate committees and qual
organizations
this campaign Finance reform package
also contains two additional Provisions
in efforts to upgrade and modernize our
campaign Finance process currently
political organizations that are not
candidate committees commonly referred
to as taxs are allowed to raise $5,000
per election in the primary and in the
general so they can raise a total of
$10,000 per donor during a two-year
cycle this reform increases that limit
to10 000 per election or $20,000 per
cycle while Federal campaign Finance
operates on a yearly limit threshold of
$10,000 per year instead of per election
this change would put our state limits
for political organization fundraising
in line with the current federal limits
organizations that are focused on state
elections and issues taking place under
this Stone should not be expected to
operate at half the limit Federal
political organizations operate on by
increasing these limits we will put our
state laws more in line with Federal
campaign Finance laws lessening the
potential for confusion from political
organizers in the states the one final
change this legislation makes is is
truly an effort to clarify and reduce
confusion from firsttime candidates for
office currently uh as you're running
for office as all as all of us know uh
we can report our campaign finances as a
candidate or set up a candidates
committee uh this legislation removed
moves the candidate category from the
state campaign Finance laws and directs
every candidate filing campaign Finance
reports towards the candidates committee
registration process this would not
require more than one person to form the
committee a candidate for office in New
Hampshire can be both the committee
chair and the treasurer this would go to
Great Lengths to reduce confusion in the
process individuals today can go on to
the Secretary of State's website and
file as a candidate for the purpose of
campaign Finance for the the 2022
election declare what office they're
seeking and what party they're part of
the current setup of the law can give
the impression to firsttime candidates
that this process of filing as a
candidate for the purposes of campaign
Finance reports is the same as the
process for filing as a candidate with
their town or city cler during the
filing window that will be held next
June by directing all candidates to form
a candidates committee we will remove
potential confusion while reducing the
categories of entities for campaign fin
reports leading to Greater transparency
in a more cohesive system overall I know
I have just presented a great deal of
information regarding the propos
legislation and I did email all of the
members this morning a copy of my
written testimony but I'm happy at this
time to take any
questions thank you representative
Sweeny representative ter roian thank
you madam chair thank you representative
taking the question so um you know I can
see some benefits to some of what you're
proposing in here but again can you
elaborate a little bit more on the on
the reason to
change um in in in the spirit of trying
to keep it simple seems to me by um
getting rid of the ability for candidate
just to be a candidate not have to form
a committee would be better than getting
rid of that he has to now form a
committee so so tell me kind of what the
bit all the others um revisions aside
tell me how that's a benefit to to uh
to have have to re require everybody
that's running to now form a committee
absolutely and and the way I view it is
truly kind of just a bookkeeping measure
uh the process for registering a
candidate committee versus just
registering as a candidate um there's no
difference between that process there's
no cost to register a candidate
Committee in the state of New Hampshire
and this legislation doesn't introduce a
cost for that it's it's really just in
an effort to to move away from having
two different categories for how a
candidate files um it's just moving
everybody into a candidate committee I I
operate a candidate committee for my
election efforts I call it Joe Sween for
New Hampshire I'm the chair and the
treasurer of it um and the process to
file as that is is as simple and
straightforward as just filing as a
candid so it doesn't change any of the
reporting requirements um it just makes
it so that it's it's it's called a
committee um and it's really just
merging my view the two entities
together one
candid thank you thank you
representative Brian thank you madam
chair uh we have a citizen legislature
in this state and that's a very positive
people are you concerned that some
people may be dissuaded from running for
office if they feel they uh
they have to form a committee where at
this point they are simply candidate but
now if they're a committee that doing
the exact same thing but they have to
call themselves a committee and it may
make things more complicated to some uh
people who are interested in serving the
state legisl um I I absolutely
understand that um and I think both
respective political parties in the
state will do everything they can to
ease that confusion with the potential
candidates that are looking to look for
office
um and I don't think we're introducing
so much of a burden where the candidates
if they're planning on spending or
raising $500 toward their election
efforts are going to have to file Curr
with the Secretary of State's office
anyways either as a candidate or as a
candidate committee um I understand the
word the wording that committee is is
the The Harbinger here I wouldn't be
opposed to just saying we'll have
everybody fil as a single entity as a
candidate um I just don't see the reason
to have candidate filings and candidates
committee filing when it's really just
one Avenue anyways and one vehicle for
people
Ence thank you representative Ross um is
there any material difference outside of
the word committee between being a
candidate or actual difference you the
fundraising limit different is the
spending limit different is the way you
Tak funds different anything different
other than the name uh to to my
knowledge there's no difference I I've
looked through in and out of the
campaign Finance laws that we have after
working in politics I don't see a
difference between filing as a candidate
and filing as a
candidate thank you representative
browan representative sweetie u i I
share a concern of making this more
complicated than necessary for uh
candidates State Rep uh I many of my
friends who rep work very hard to stay
under the $500 because they just don't
want the hassle of reping um 500 has
been in place at least since 2008 when I
got involved uh and I believe it was
before that you be receptive to adding
to your bill amendment to raise the 500
to, 1500 because let's face it
$1,500 is not a huge amount of political
influence in today's climate and it
would allow a much larger number of
people not to have to file at all which
would reduce the Secretary of State's
work reduce the candidates work and I I
think it would it would alleviate some
of the concerns about making this too
complicated for people who don't plan to
go raise a lot of
money thank you representative for the
question I I wouldn't see a problem with
that many legislation that the committee
uh were so motivated to to amend the the
legislation to that effect
they wouldn't have opposition
for thank you representative to I'm
going to go to some members online first
and then come back to thank you madam
chair representative
Lane yes thank you madam chair I have a
couple of questions um do you want me to
ask for follow-ups uh each time go ahead
representative Lane I I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you go ahead
representative Lane without followup
permission okay all I might cut you off
after 20 or 30 minutes but well
hopefully will not take that long uh I
guess my question was why is this needed
to why is it why do we need to raise the
contribution limits to be consistent
with Federal in a state like New
Hampshire that's small and local most of
these races are
local um so so I'll say so we we don't
raise the contribution limit for the
candidates we just allow them to raise
the
$7,000 more so throughout the election
cycle we raised the contribution this
bill raises the contribution limits for
political organizations uh just to just
to kind of progress our laws that update
update the current existing laws that
haven't been updated in in a while I'm
not sure when the $5,000 limit was set
into statute um but the cost of of
campaigns in between the the Republican
party and the Democrat Party just the
party committees um in 2020 I know the
Republicans have raised and spent on the
state side $1.7 million and the
Democrats have raised and spent $4.3
million um so there's definitely not a
there's not a lack of money in the
system currently going towards political
organizations in the state um but just
to up update the donor limit from 5,000
to 10,000 I think reflects the increased
cost of campaigning increased cost that
political organizations have in the
state um there are a number of political
organizations that
operate 365 days a year both years of
the election cycle they not just set up
as a candidates committee would be just
during the election time they are
constantly raising money and constantly
making expenditures uh in efforts to uh
to win elections in the grandon state um
so I just think it's time in 2021 to
update the limits that was myself and
the other Bill sponsors to just update
the limits for p oration throughout the
gr State across the
board okay um also did I understand you
to say that you reducing the reporting
periods um in your bill so so not so
there's still going to be the same
schedule of when reports are due for
campaign Finance reports uh but
currently uh when you file with the
Secretary of State's office you have an
exploratory phase that you report under
then you have the primary phase then the
general election phase and then the
reports under this bill the reports
would just have the primary election
period and the general election period
so there' only be two periods of on the
reports listed in the column that's
that's submitted to the Secretary of
State's office but this does not change
the schedule of reporting uh that's
currently in
statute and why why would you want to
reduce the to remove the exploratory
period where were there problem so just
the way that the the the the other
changes in the bill regarding candidate
filings moving it from that $5,000 that
someone can raise in the exploratory
base the $1,000 in the primary and the
$1,000 in the general that is changed to
the $3,500 in the primary and $3500 in
the general and there's no exploratory
phase under campaign Finance laws and
and and honestly the the current setup
is is great for protecting incumbents uh
because incumbents have all the time in
the world to raise those big dollars
from from donors early on in the cycle
um if you are and we don't really deal
with it running for state representative
but if you're running for state senate
or you're running for executive councel
um and you decide to a few weeks before
filing or a month before filing uh
you're going to see a massive drop off
in your ability to fund raise the moment
you sign up for office which I think is
is a bad uh practice under the current
law and allowing candidates to continue
to fund raise while they're
campaigning while while people are
paying attention on will benefit the
candidates and benefit the ERS in the
state so that they just it really gets
rid of that exploratory phase and the
minute you start raising money for a
campaign you're entered into the primary
portion of the campaign even without
filing for the
office okay thank
you representative
berron thank you madam chairman uh my
question goes back to the issue of
creating candidate committees and um
well I I recognize that there's actually
no difference in filing uh reports
whether you're a candidate or a
committee
um a lot of state representatives like
to separate their money so that they
have a separate account for example for
their campaign contributions when I
established a committee my bank required
that I get an employee identification
number in order to open up an account
under that committee's name um wouldn't
this bill create new hurdles for
candidates to set up accounts where they
can separate their campaign contribution
and expenditures from their personal
accounts um I I don't see any reason why
it would I think that that just depends
on the bank that the candidates using um
but I I don't see any reason why someone
wouldn't be able to form a candidate's
committee and still form file an account
using their social security number
existing account and just create another
account at their Bank um so I'm not
aware of a bank that would require um
but obviously it seems that in your
experience you have I know when I set up
my committee account uh as Citizens Bank
I just needed to provide my social um
but if that is if that is an actual
issue with with the committee process um
then I'm obvious open to the changes
with that to make sure that candidates
don't have to file with for banking
purposes um but I'm not aware fully that
that is the norm for banks or that Banks
wouldn't be allowed to create an account
or if you created a committee Paul
berson for for rep or for N I don't see
why Paul berson can't set up an account
for those funds um we
know unlike Federal Finance laws the
state newshire doesn't ask for what your
bank account information is or where you
do your banking campaign Finance
proportions um so I'm not sure if the
account name or or how the account is
filed to to segregate the funds from
personal accounts falls under campaign
Finance
La okay thank you
representative thank you representative
teros thank you madam chair thank you
representative for the uh additional
question so I heard you in testimony I'm
going to get back on the campaign versus
the committee there's no really material
difference or material benefit to change
that line would you be agreeable to an
amendment just to allow the candidate
the option to like it is now to be
either candidate or have a
committee um to the committee if that's
the committee wishes uh I will say the
the morphing candidates committee and C
filings into one entity uh was not the
the main force of this of this
legislation um I view it simply as
cleaning up the existing statute but
obviously as the as the committee wishes
to proceed the committee will proceed um
I I look at it as someone who has helped
candidates and firsttime candidates uh
before and feeled questions regarding
the differences between filing as a
candidate filing as the candidates
committee I I personally don't see a lot
of reasons to have the two separate
but if the committee so chooses I
definitely it's not going to be the part
of the bill that I'm going to fely Def
thank
you are there any other committee
members in the room representative home
o'ban thank you
chair this bill uh encompasses a few
different
issues and I
I I feel like it it
they could stand alone in their own
bills one of them is repealing the the
voluntary expenditure
limits I've never really felt that I'm
affected by that
um why does that affect can candidates
that choose not to engage with the volun
expend I just don't understand
feel wants to
try uh I I personally view the voluntary
expenditure limit as an outdated piece
of state law that was intended to reduce
the amount of money spent in our
elections and the number of candidates
that actually agree to the limits uh
proves that the amount of money that's
spent in our elections proves that the
intent of the law never really followed
through never effective um and I'm a fan
of updating and operating state law
wherever we can um and I just see a
cleaner system going forward would be
one without voluntary expenditure limits
um as it reduces confusion with
candidate filings and we've have both
sides of the aisle had candidates in the
past that they're they're they're not
they're they know what they're running
for they know what they want to run for
and it's their first time running and
they'll agree to a voluntary expenditure
limit without knowing that they're
agreeing to a voluntary expenditure
limit and the impact that has not only
on their campaigns but on what others
are spending without without even
communicating with the candidates
uh creates headaches and I think it's
it's truly an outdated uh model to to
reduce campaign spending and I don't
think the state personally I don't think
the state of New Hampshire should be
providing incentives to to reduce the
amount of
spending representative Ross the current
voluntary expenditure definition where
you can take effectively
$5,000 5,000 $15,000 from one donor that
system provide actually the the whole
point of campaign Finance laws right is
to prevent What's called the the gift
effect which is where you give somebody
something and human psychology dictates
that later that should be paid back
wouldn't that voluntary expenditure
level open that GI Dynamic up wider for
somebody that can stroke a $115,000
check versus somebody having to raise
smaller smaller contri students I I
agree completely I I view I view where
all candidates are tapped at the $7,000
per donor limit over the entire cycle
increases the importance of of smaller
donors um and also just makes it so that
candidates you know can't have that gift
effect that donations might to them and
I I agree with you I I VI campaign
Finance laws um we need to be able to
make them as transparent as possible and
as as willing for people to be able to
comply as possible um and I think the
changes this bill make it so that
candidates can can more easily comply
with all the pieces of campaign Finance
law and makes it and I know there's
obviously a lot of things in the bill
but I do think this makes it a more
streamlined process and more explainable
process to firsttime candidates that
compliance further questions from
committee members in the room committee
members attending electronically does
anybody have any other questions for
representative
Sweeny
I'm seeing none thank you representative
anybody else signed up to speak ahead of
time on this bill are there any
attendees who wish to speak in regards
hand I'm not seeing any so I am going to
Bill
263 the next item on our agenda is House
105 um I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 105 this is relative to
political contributions made by limited
liability
companies I have a number of people
signed up to to speak on this bill and
and representative
McGee um has signed up and
is the sponsor of the
bill so representative N I have
hopefully promoted you to be with us and
welcome thank you uh Madame chairwoman
and distinguished members of election
law can you hear me he can thank you oh
great I was having trouble with my
microphone so I just wanted to check um
I'm representative cat McGee as you
heard from Hillsboro 27 Hollis I come
before you here today as the prime
sponsor of HB 105 affectionately known
as the LLC loophole Bill U many of you
may remember this legislation from last
time around um New Hampshire campaign
Finance laws attempt to create some
controls that prohibit the UN undue
influence of money in politics and HB
105 helps to make that real this bill
reestablishes the intent of RSA 664
colon 4 um Section Five by ensuring that
the identity of a donor behind the LLC
is revealed before uh for political
contributions uh to prevent the current
loophole that permits multiples of the
campaign contribution limit from being
submitted by an individual donor who has
multiple llc's available to them as
members of election law I'm sure you're
interested in supporting transparency
and accountability where possible and
this is a bipartisan effort as it was in
the last session to plug the LLC
loophole for the State of New Hampshire
so a little background in 2010 there was
a gubernatorial candidate John Steven
who caused a stir when he raised over
$100,000 from 30 limited liability
corporations registered from just two
addresses in the states of Massachusetts
in Connecticut and the donations ended
up uh being traced back to an LL uh I'm
sorry an LLC that that uh represented
Dunkin Donuts
franchises uh 13 llc's using the same
addresses gave New Hampshire
gubernatorial candidate Kevin Smith
donations that went well beyond the
individual legal limit nearly $100,000
of Smith's contributions came from llc's
that were from those same addresses that
I mentioned uh in the prior example the
bundling of donations from the same
individual is clearly in con conflict
with the intent of the New Hampshire
contribution limit statute but nothing
in the current law prohibits multiple
limited liability companies controlled
by the same individual from donating the
maximum on behalf of each
LLC uh to compound their influence
making it easy for these donors to flout
the spirit of the law and exceed the
statutory individual limits so uh my
Republican co-sponsors on hb1 5
Representatives gay and Gunther were
happy to sign on again they had been
co-sponsors in the prior session um and
I am not sure whether they're online
because we can't see who who's waiting
um to speak to you today but I would
appreciate your vote in uh ought to pass
to fix this loophole to protect the
state of New Hampshire from the unfair
use of our campaign Finance laws by the
Brazen few thank you for your time and
I'm happy to take questions if I if I
can answer them I will
questions for Miss mcke from committee
members in the room representative Ross
uh yes do Union have this same sort of
as you call it loophole and do they ever
use it as do they take money in from
members and then redistribute candidates
underneath their own
name I I you know I think it's a good
question and the way I would view this
is that this is a fairly narrow cast
bill it doesn't solve every every
campaign Finance violation or every
Brazen act uh that could be identified
it's it's specifically targeted to look
at the abuse uh from the LLC perspective
and I I'm not sure that any of the
unions are set up that way I think that
would go more into you know packs and
other ways that people organize in order
to bundle money so I understand the
point of your question but I think this
is distinct from that and and if someone
else has a different perspective I'm
happy to hear it but I I actually think
this is just specifically targeted to
RSA 664 colon 4 on how LLC contributions
will be
handled um which is that there is a
limit that is set by legislation and
that that limit is now being
um you know averted by folks who are
figuring out ways around the
limit um cross Paul you said that going
back to my first question about
specifically you said it's distinct and
different but how is it distinct and
different how is it not the exact same
thing I think if a union is set up as an
LLC then it would fall under this
particular legislation and I'm not sure
that unions are set up that way so
distinction thank you further questions
from members of the committee in the
room I thought I I hand over here see
none question from committee
members
online I'm not seeing any hand raised
any further
representative I'm seeing none thank you
representative mcge yes thank you
chairwoman
Griffin also signed up to speak on this
bill is Ryan Beal I think I pronounced
your last name correct
um from open democracy action good
morning good morning Madam chair and
committee members um I am Brian Beal I'm
director uh a deputy director of open
democracy action which is a proter
nonpartisan nonprofit based in conquered
and I reside in Alton Bay New Hampshire
uh let me Begin by saying that the
personal New Hampshire contribution
limit to a candidate in the state in a
state election is
$7,000 not
$25,000 not $30,000 not
$100,000 an analysis I did in December
2019 of the 2020 gubinatorial candidates
for six months this is important six
month period of June 6th to uh 2019 to
December 4th 2019 shows that llc's were
used extensively in the 2020 campaign
cycle to funnel money above that $7,000
limit for donors wanting to give more
than the New Hampshire that New
Hampshire allows I sent the source
documents via email to you all um along
with a spreadsheet that I'm going to
reference um while I speak the data took
three days to assemble uh because of our
state's archaic Reporting System the LLC
data had to First be keyed into a
spreadsheet because it was submitted by
facts sorted by addresses and names and
then the O LLC ownership identified
through corporate records not exactly a
transparent process two of the three
gubinatorial candidates took money from
llc's during this period Senator Dan
felus took eight donations from llc's
totaling $
5,538 all it appears from separate
organizations Andrew valinsky took no
money from llc's during that period and
Governor Chris anunu took money from 36
167,50 22 of the llc's donating to
governor sununu's uh campaign were
either from the same address or
controlled by only six individuals in
corporations totaling
$147,200
most of these 22 llc's were donating the
maximum of $7,000 each for one donor a
New Hampshire developer and hotel owner
and his spouse $28,000 was donated
through a combination of individual
donations an LLC and two corporations
all controlled by the same people Arthur
Brady with another Manchester real
estate uh company Brady Sullivan used
five different llc's from the using the
same address as its offices to make
donations totaling
$333,000 Brady Sullivan has used llc's
consistently over the S past several
elections Summit Land Development LLC
owned by Charles I think it's kry uh
didn't do the maximum with his llc's he
just contributed $25,000 in six months
through five llc's giving $5,000 each
Joseph Pharaoh owner of Tuscan Kitchen
and a developer was one of the most
difficult to track down having llc's in
two states that donated uh Mr Pharaoh
personally donated to $7,000 then added
donations from New Boston subdivision
Holdings LLC JNS Investments LLC omj
reality LLC Tuscan Brands LLC to total
$30,000 in donations in one six-month
period another real estate family
Michael Kane and John Kane used a
similar tactic to Brady Sullivan using U
uh four corporate addresses um all with
it uh as an example 162 Corporate Drive
LLC 166 Etc uh Michael and John Kane
donated increments of $5,000 for a total
of
$25,000 there are more but I'll spare
you it's bad enough that corporations
are making direct donations to
candidates in our state something which
has been out louded now in many states
um but to have these individuals
bamboozle the spirit of our campaign
Finance laws is really insulting I'll
end my testimony the way I began the New
Hampshire personal contribution limit to
a candidate in the state election is
$7,000 please vote ought to pass on HB
105 thank you very much for your
testimony is there anybody in the room
who has the question representative
sweee thank you madam chair and thank
you uh for taking my question um and
this may have some follow-ups do you
believe that business owners uh in the
granted state are affected uh by the
outcome of elections in the granted
State
certainly if if if those same business
owners have multiple businesses and each
business is recognized separately as an
LLC as its own
why would we limit those businesses that
may have interests and may have skin in
the game if you will from making their
voice heard through their political
contributions why would their free
speech they have a h a personal limit of
$7,000 uh as it is currently the
statute per personally but we allow we
currently allow the we currently allow
llc's to to meet those personal limits
as well um and this bill changes that
and I'm just trying to wrap my head as
to why we would limit the the political
speech of those of those entities well
the entities are are owned by those
individuals so this bill uh an LLC
doesn't have any political speech I'm
sorry I'm asking onea if you can please
mute you were you have been recognized
and spoken and are not part of the
discussion at this point thank you I'm
sorry didn't know there's no way for me
to unmute I don't have any option to do
anything you're not recogniz thank you
Miss McGee I'm sorry we we're sort of
doing the technical thing ourselves I've
just muted you thank you representative
Sweeney I I have no further followup all
right representative ter Roan thank you
madam chair thank you sir for taking my
question you're still there certainly I
think we all agree there's lots of money
in in campaigns these days and the
numbers going up uh there many types of
doners and donations
for for comparison purposes could you
give similar figures to the players you
just mentioned for monies um in
donations from trade unions in the state
or perhaps even out of the state well
there is a another bill before you today
which addresses uh uh the donations
coming from corporations and trade
unions specifically uh trade unions are
not part of this bill so um it it's it's
about a portioning this bill is about
apportioning uh the uh the percentage of
ownership in the llc's toward a uh a a
personal donor's
total so uh if you own uh a 20% share of
that LLC that's making the donation that
amount would be go to your personal uh
donation total but it does not involve
trade
unions thank you representative Mooney
thank you m thank you for your testimony
I apprciate all of the examples that you
gave I'm wondering if you could further
break down some of the examples or any
example you gave as applicable to the
formula in the bill for example in the
case of Tusk kitchen you mentioned all
the llc's and so forth with a total
approv of
35,000 if uh that LLC
scenario was applied to this law what
would be the outcome based on the LLC Lo
and so
on access to this information is very
difficult um so as I said it's not a
transparent system and when I did this
research I can see who are stockholders
U or owners in these corporations but I
do not have the uh tools
uh to be able to identify what
percentage they have follow
LLC thank you very much well then I have
a followup thank you if you're not able
to see the percentage of ownership in
the
implemented I would you'd have to
disclose this information uh you'd be
asking the
requiring the uh owners of these llc's
making the donations what the percentage
of their ownership is in that LLC
currently if you look at the reports
you'll see individuals that make
donations have to disclose their
business
affiliations right so that that would be
uh uh an additional step that that L
that llc's would have to do so you'll
see on the leftand side of the campaign
Finance reports of the candidates you'll
see names of individuals but then you'll
see names of Corporations and uh names
of llc's names of unions if that's
applicable um uh and you'll see those
and then you would want to dis have
another column that would disclose what
the percentage of that ownership was in
the L in in an L LLC so part of my
process was to go through and match up
the individuals with those llc's but I
you'd have to require that
representative Ross question chairman um
you're here with the open democracy
which you say is a nonpartisan group
correct uh I work uh in in this capacity
I'm uh representing open democracy
action which is a 501c C4 I assume it's
democracy right um is there a single
member of your board who is not a
Democrat uh is that drum main to this uh
we have uh we have actually a number of
Republicans as part of our U advisory
committee um we work with we work with
everybody and we worked um throughout
the election on helping everybody to
vote doesn't matter what what color um
your uh party I'm just I'm specifically
asking because you mentioned in your
testimony that you're nonpartisan but
I'm familiar with your board and and I
would respectfully say the opposite I'm
not talking about the work we do I'm
talking about the board thank you
further
questions further questions from
attendees excuse me from our panelists
electronically I'm not seeing any thank
you very much for your testimony this
morning thank you madam
chair also signed up this morning to
speak on uh this bill is Liz tentarelli
Liz are you here could you raise your
hand I see you there you are thank you
very
welcome you're with us
now thank you for this opportunity to
speak Madam chair um I sent you written
testimony in support of this bill as one
small step for campaign Finance reform
and in that I pointed out that a similar
Bill SB
156 passed both the house and the senate
in
2019 uh unfortunately it was one of the
57 bills vetoed by the governor that
year but there was strong bipartisan
support for this bill in 2019 and I
would ask you to look at it today after
I sent my written testimony I wanted to
do a bit more research not as
extensively as Mr Beal succeeded in
doing however but I did I was curious
about how many
llc's there are that are primarily
single member
llc's and how many are entity owned and
I found an article in the new Hampshire
Business review of September 29th
2019 this was an article written by John
Cunningham Esquire who is an LLC legal
expert in our state and he wrote there
are tens of thousands of New Hampshire
llc's that's that's disturbing if you
think that uh I realize they're not
mostly set up for campaign donations but
if the single owners of those llc's
wanted to donate and create you know
even more of these single member llc's
they could do it so this bill puts a bit
of a break on that uh llc's have
certainly other uses they need to be
used and so on oops I'm sorry you're
seeing my ceiling I just realized I
apologize for that I was going to ask
you to to to move your camera but I'm
not sure in the zoom World whether
that's considered good etiquette or not
so you know maybe it was not good
etiquette of me to have it aimed at the
ceiling so I
apologize um but in addition to those
tens of thousands of single member
llc's there are hundreds of thousands of
entity owned single member
llc's and um I'm sure if Mr Cunningham
could explain exactly what that means it
would be interesting but the point I
wish to make is that this could have a
huge impact if people want to circumvent
our very sensible campaign Finance
reforms uh Finance laws by using the
llc's without this law that you're
considering today so on behalf of the
leue of Women Voters I am strongly
urging you to support House Bill
105 thank
you questions from members in the
remotely thank you Miss tenerelli I I do
have a question and this is sort of
longstanding and I can't remember when
you say on behalf of the League of Women
Voters you're talking about New
Hampshire right yes I am and so has the
New Hampshire your executive director
has the has the New Hampshire board
actually met to vote on the things that
you appeared before us on or not
actually I am the President I am a
volunteer I am elected by the board and
the uh board does meet not to vote on
specific bills as this is but rather we
work from a set of positions that have
been adopted over the years through a
process of study and
consensus uh llc's are a very specific
part of this but the nation league has
done a study on campaign Finance
reforms which the state League uh is uh
supports and so it is on that basis that
I am speaking for our state league and
actually the national league would would
support this as well but uh I I am not
speaking for them
today so you're speaking in Your
Capacity as executive director volunteer
in in interpretation of the policies
adopted by New Hampshire leg one voters
I am speaking as president of that
organization yes in which all members
have a voice in developing those
positions and then they are formally
adopted by the board in order to use in
our advocacy work like this thank you
thank
you thank you for being with us this
morning uh also signed up to speak on
this bill is Jim Ruben
Mr Rubin you have been electronically
asked to join us to speak and I believe
at this point you may good morning Mr
Rubin good morning I I I don't know if I
look dark to you here but thank you
members of the committee for having me
uh this morning I speak in favor of an
ought to pass motion on HB 105 I come in
representation as a board member of
American promise a National Organization
working on campaign money reform and I
speak as the New England chairman of
takeback a republic the leading
conservative organization nationally
working on campaign uh political reform
in general and campaign money reform a
little tiny bit of background I'm former
state senator republican from the Upper
Valley area I live in Hanover in Etna I
am former chairman of the Hampshire GOP
platform committee served on two
separate legislatively authorized
campaign money commissions which have
wrestled with these and and many issues
associated with the campaign money
reform
uh I have uh run for governor as a
republican for US Senate twice as a
republican so I've got quite a bit of
experience also senior a political
adviser for Gordon Humphrey when he ran
for governor as a republican in the
primary for New Hampshire so I've got a
lot of different types of experience
dealing with campaign money issues both
as a candidate as an adviser and as a as
a volunteer in organizations so again
there are just two points I'd like to
make in favor of the out to pass motion
here on this bill is the the general
value of campaign money limits and the
uh the need to close what really here is
a specifically identified gaping
loophole in the money limits we have
here in New Hampshire so first the value
of limits and I know many conservatives
like myself uh support the citizens
united decision which uh forbid limits
in many types of expending but
specifically authorized and supported
direct to candidate contribution limits
so one one of the bedrocks of
conservative thinking about campaign
money is the 2010 citizens united
decision it specifically authorized
condoned both transparency reporting so
that people know where the money is
coming from and direct to candidate uh
contribution limits so this bill is very
consistent with with the conservative
Bedrock of of thinking about campaign
money uh the value of limits uh I go
back to the framers of our constitution
they were keenly deeply concerned about
two things one of which was the prospect
of tyranny when you concentrate power as
large sums of money spent on individual
candidates tends to do uh it tends to
increase risk of tyranny concentration
of power abuse of power and secondly
risks of corruption the founders framer
of our framers of our US Constitution
thought very very carefully about
dispersing power when you allow when you
allow large sums of money I.E through
this LLC loophole uh concentrated uh
sources of money to flow to a specific
candidate you increase the risk of
corruption and you uh increase the risk
of undue influence uh our government is
structured specifically structured to
keep influence broad because we have a
government uh thought by by one of our
framers Madison to be accountable solely
to the citizens the people of the
country in this case the constituents of
a person in New Hampshire who might be a
candidate for for New Hampshire office
so by having limits we disperse
influence and we reduce risk of
corruption we reduce risk of
concentration of power and and and the
risk of tyranny secondly just it it's
fairly obvious this this bill doesn't
seek to correct every single means by
which uh campaign money can be
concentrated into into one hand and
thereby increase influence on a
particular candidate but this is a known
identified loophole it can be closed
simply it's a simple short Bill uh
therefore I uh urge a to pass thank you
members of the committee and Madam
chairman thank you Mr Rubin members of
the committee present in the room with
questions The Honorable Mr
rubben committee
members yes M yes Madam chair I have a
question representative Cody thank you
madam chair first of all I'd like to
welcome my old friend Senator Rubin back
to the
legislature we miss him around here I
think
lots of times I would I would like to
ask you Senator what particular uh
abuses you see the LLC process
particularly um evidencing in in this
area I I'm not going to ask you about
how your
organization uh what your organization's
decisionmaking process is thank you
yeah both organizations take back our
Republic again the leading conservative
organization focused on campaign reform
political reform and American promise
another National Organization I whose
board I sit see the value as is evident
in Hampshire's campaign law in
dispersing power in in making sure that
uh individual members of our legislature
our governor our members of our
executive Council are accountable to all
their constituents on a broad basis
again that the the theory here and I'm
not going to identify any specific
instance of corruption I don't know of
any specific in in in in instance I'm
I'm a very strong supporter myself of
Republicans I give money to Republicans
I strongly support our governor however
there is a risk when you allow a single
individual to concentrate large sums of
money in the form of a contribution to a
particular candidate and that
candidate comes into office that
particular
voice that donor voice is Amplified and
the risk of that is that the broad range
of citizens constituents that that that
candidate that member of the legislature
Governor executive Council represents
might be uh might be silent suppressed
less listened to so what we're doing is
we're eliminating risk this is
completely consistent with campaign
Finance law in New Hampshire very
consistent with citizens united which
sees value in dispersing power this is
completely consistent with our framers
and founders structuring of the
Constitution to make sure that we don't
have concentrated power and that we make
sure that government is accountable
solely to to the people in this case to
constituents so this is deeply
consistent with fundamental conservative
values the structure of our government
at the state and federal level I don't
know if that answers your question or
not thank you it does thank
you however I will Senator Rubin with
your permission ask and follow up
representative Cody having reminded me
committee members do not have the
advantage of the the signup sheet which
I have which has individuals signed up
as representing an organization but
speaking as a member of the public so
Senator Rubin if you could clarify you
signed up as representing American
promise um but are identified as a
member of the public so in what capacity
are you appearing here this morning
like the like the last question right
both American promise and uh and
takeback our Republic have not examined
this particular bill but both
organizations uh support limits to
individual contributions to candidate
and this loophole in our state law
allows essentially unlimited
contributions controlled by and sourced
from a single individual so so the
loophole in our state law is uh totally
consistent with the primary mission of
two organizations that I that I work
with so just for my further
clarification um is it fair to say that
you're a volunteer member of those
organizations then which is why you're
not appearing as a lobbyist in both case
I'm not paid not paid anything to do
you representative representative Sweeny
thank thank you madam chair and thank
you uh Senator Rubin for taking my
question um so just off of off of Madam
chair's question uh so you are here
today representing multiple
entities correct followup representative
s would you say those multiple entities
have their own political economy in in
their
operations you mean are they dependent
on sources of money that flow to
them uh
I I can say an answer to that you know
reflecting on the on the last question
or to the last person the prior person
giving testimony take back our Republic
is very heavily conservative uh board
members and
staff and
advisers we we are we can make a very
solid claim to being the nation's
leading organization conservative
backing campaign reform and political
reform
thank
you other members of the committee with
questions in the room or
online I'm not seeing any hands up thank
you Senator Rubin you also signed up to
Perry uh good morning morning M good
morning Madam chair and members of the
committee
am I framed correctly or is
my here okay didn't know whether I was
pointing at the water stain in the
ceiling no actually your video I don't I
just have your
name
okay um I I speak in in support of HB
105 and depending on when I speak you
will have heard or are yet to hear uh in
great detail the current legal abuses of
money in politics that tilt political
influence heavily in favor of the
wealthy under current law one person
owning multiple llc's May leverage his
or her campaign
contributions by the number of llc's
that one person owns like Jerry
mandering political power shifts away
from segments of the
population because state legislatures or
in this case gubernatorial veto have
allowed for unfair advantage to
perpetuate it's akin to the early
discussion in America's history about
the right to vote that only wealthy land
owners be given the
franchise the Brennan senate for justice
confirms that over the decades quote the
US Supreme Court as well as lower courts
have repeatedly and consistently upheld
state and federal laws requiring
disclosures of who is spending money in
politics end quote in the citizens
united ruling
and otherwise Goliath ruling against
David the majority concluded
transparency is key to democracy quoting
quote transparency enables the
electorate to make informed decisions
and give proper weight to different
speakers and messages end quote in the
case of the LLC Le blue pole the public
is not being informed as to who is
influencing our elections instead only
being informed as to the entity making
those
contributions thus doubly offensive to
democracy one individual making multiple
campaign contribution through ownership
of multiple
llc's and then LLC members making
campaign contributions
anonymously HB 105 is before you today
because Governor sununu vetoed the
previous version in referring to the
Minority Report on SB
156 whose language is identical to this
bill I respectfully disagree with this
conclusion that elimination of the LLC
loophole would prove harmful to the PRI
privacy of LLC members I remind all who
serve in the legislature that you are
required to disclose all donations over
$25 including the names
addresses and
occupations of those donors contrasted
with current law allowing hundreds or
thousands of dollars to be contributed
to campaigns without attribution to
individual LLC members under campaign
Finance
laws there is no justification for the
elevation of political influence by
those wealthy enough to knowingly
disadvantage the rest of us in the
maintenance of democracy there is
however every justification for
supporting uh for support of filling in
the hole of Dak money
spending
and I thank the
committee thank you Mr
Perry are there any questions for Mr
Perry from members of the committee in
the
room questions for Mr Perry from
committee
members let me just check to make sure I
don't have any hands up anywhere I'm not
seeing any thank you for joining us Mr
Perry thank you also signed up to speak
welcome um thank you very much but Brian
Beal has spoken for our organization and
I don't need to add additional time to
this
hearing than thank
you also uh with a request to not signed
scanland thank you madam chair members
of the committee I'm David scanland
deputy secretary of state here not to
take a position uh on House Bill 105 but
to point out that both this bill and the
one prior probably should have been uh
sent out for a fiscal note um I can tell
you that some programming changes would
be required to our online campaign
Finance system to accommodate the
changes in both bills um I would also
point out that uh the Attorney General's
office would probably see increased uh
enforcement expenses in terms of uh what
would be required of them to look into
uh members of llc's to make sure that
they are uh have been properly recorded
in any contributions that the LLC makes
questions questions from the committee
electronically Deputy scanland I'm not
seeing anybody asking questions uh I do
have one though uh currently the LLC
formation and Reporting
requirements do not require disclosure
of members is that corre of all members
correct
yes all right thank
you I just wanted to make sure I
understood that
Curr any further questions from anybody
I did oh I'm sorry I I'm looking for a
hand on screen and you were there go
ahead yeah I tried to do both but it it
was a challenge um thank you um Deputy
scalan U when you the fiscal notes were
those done when the bill was was
previously done can we look at those um
or or did we neglect to do it last time
too uh representative L I would have to
go back and look uh to see if they were
done last time and also see if the if
the bills are identical or if there are
know at least settle differences between
the
two and may I have a followup
please go ahead sure my understanding
deput scandin is and I haven't seen it
but I had understood that there was a
bill pending that might require
disclosure of LLC members is that
correct do you know uh I don't know I'd
be happy to look it but I'm not aware of
that this session but it's not to say it
doesn't exist yes somebody asked me to
sponsor it and I don't know what
happened so maybe they decided not to to
go forward thank you probably have gone
to Commerce if it made it through the
enrollment process
yeah I'll check it out thank you all
questions all right not seeing any I'm
GNA close um the hearing this morning on
HB 105 and that brings us to our next
noticed hearing um which would be hp91
but that is not noticed till 1:00 so we
have an unexpected long lunch break um I
will in the in the interest of sort of
going forward here I have extreme
interest in getting our first bill exact
today and it seems to me that 127 would
be a perfect Bill to do it um so uh
perhaps at the end of the day if if
members could take a look at that bill
and the testimony we received this
morning which was to itl it uh perhaps
we can address it thank you and we're on
go
we are unmuted mad chairman all right
the election law committee is back
online we have a couple minutes before
then
[Music]
um
I
for
all right everybody I guess we're set it
is 1 o'clock this is the election law
committee we have a hearing scheduled on
HB
391 relative to increasing the threshold
for reporting by
political
committees um and I have asked
representative Sweeny to introduce the
swe thank you m chair members of this
committee I am not a sponsor on this
legislation but I am introducing it this
bill as you
says increases the dollar threshold for
reporting by phot committees currently
under New Hampshire law is individual
gives $25 or more to a political
organization or a candidate in the
stampare their name and address is
publicized on the campaign Finance
reports uh this bill would increase that
threshold to
$100 uh committee research indicated
that the last time that the dollar
amount was changed was
1982 um so roughly this is really just
keeping up with inflation and the
changes cost of what $25 was in 1982
would be around $100 today um and I
would just like to the members of the
committee keep in mind that currently
for federal campaign Finance laws uh
individual donors are not reported uh
itemized receipts unless they donate
more than $200 towards any particular
organization um again I'm not as on this
bill I am happy take questions if anyone
has this I just want to introduce the
legislation to start the discussion
today thank you representative swey are
there any questions from any committee
members in the committee
room any questions
electronically I'm not seeing any thank
Sweeney um I don't have anybody else
signed up to speak on this bill is there
anybody else in
attendance remotely that would like to
speak on this bill if so please feel
391 I'm not seeing anything so thank you
everybody I'm going to close the public
391 our next public hearing is
465 and that's scheduled to begin in 10
minutes uh the chair apologizes for
scheduling and having so much downtime I
the testimony this week
is dramatically different than what we
have seen in previous weeks so in 10
4465 um in the meantime the notice is is
that there can be executive
session um on any Bill throughout the
day so given that we have 10 minutes
before our next public
hearing uh I would like the committee to
consider uh
hb0
7 representative toosan do you have a
motion okay and um I thought we was
going to be 483 but I now 127 relating
to representative Silver's Bill where he
asked us to I no worries yes so I have a
motion for House Bill
127 motion is the itl legislation thank
you representative Barry it's been moved
seconded to recommend that the house itl
HB
127 um does are there any members of the
committee that have anything that they'd
like to say before I ask the clerk to
call the role um yes Madam chair I I
don't generally approve of the custom of
taking up bills prior to 24 hours after
the hearing but in this case I
understand the situation thank you thank
you representative Cody I'm doing my
best to not do that and to notice things
but I am starting to quiver over 50
bills to be voted on by crossover day so
I appr yes Madam yes Madam chair and I
understand I didn't want the doctrine of
estole to be used against me in the
future okay thank you representative
toos thank you madam chair I'll just
speak to the motion just briefly in case
anybody's on now that wasn't on this
morning we heard from the prime sponsor
who who asked us to consider iail him a
bill and we also um understood it was
wasn't wasn't necessary after talking to
U the department that
uh do that deals with this sort of thing
so I motion I believe is an order thank
you any further discussion from
committee
members we are an executive session so
I'm going to call for the vote um if the
clerk could call the
role
you skip for me to the end this is it'll
take two years to get to hang that one
so don't worry okay representative
McDonald uh yes representative food home
O'Brien yes representative Sweeny yes
representative
Hayward yes representative Mooney yes
representative to Roan yes
representative Barry yes representative
gr yes representative quy yes says yes
representative Cody yes representative
Veron right no I don't see I don't see
I don't think she checked in at the
beginning of the
day representative Hammer amyr
yes representative Lane yes
representative
brus
yes representative pet
yes representative
deal so is the vote 18 to
zero yes move consent so the vote is 18
to zero um unless a member of the
committee has an objection that would go
on the consent
calendar I'm not seeing any objections
so that will go on the consent calendar
for the first house day thank you thank
you very much
everybody that is terrific okay we still
have a few more minutes until our next
hearing at 1:15 so we will start then
thank
that
H I can
play they don't know what the hell I'm
doing I don't know what the hell I'm
good
uned that all right and I believe the
video is on so it is 1:15 just so people
are Weare of going by the clock on my
computer here in front of me um if I
don't see any objections out there I'm
presuming I'm being heard just fine this
is a public hearing
on HB 46 five relative to permissible
campaign
contributions by business organizations
and labor unions and I believe
representative Reed is here to introduce
this bill um representative Reed I'm
just doing this so I remember can you go
online after your testimony today and
sign up to speak on the bill Madam chair
if you can hear me I did already do so I
just did so uh
more recently than the 30 minute cut
offs for which I apologize that's fine I
just want to make sure you're on the
list because I don't know what happens
to us all if you don't make it on it's
happening on like all of the bills so
we'll find out so welcome this afternoon
representative re thank you madam
chairwoman um for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 17 the
towns of newfields and New Market um
this bill is a housekeeping measure um
and it actually pass the house if my
memory serves it was one of mine that
was on consent last year and
unfortunately was one of the very many
casualties of the Senate inaction due to
covid so here it is again um for some
historical context um n in 1907 then
president Teddy Roosevelt signed into
law the Tillman act which remains in
effect today this bans all corporate
donations to um political campaigns on
the Federal level around that same time
New Hampshire also as you know State
races are separate from federal uh New
Hampshire had also banned uh corporate
donations to political campaigns in the
state of New Hampshire and that law
stood until the New Hampshire Supreme
Court case in 1999 Kennedy V
Gardner and the uh Supreme Court struck
down the law because it had been overly
Broad and most of my hopefully very
brief testim testimony will be quoting
that case report that Kennedy V Gardner
case so just so you understand why they
Struck it down it the language was Broad
and banned all types of contributions
from corporations but there are
essentially two ways of Corporation can
uh can contribute one through their
General funds this is the and just to
quote the case uh report generally
corporate political contributions come
from two different sources one is the
corporation's operating or treasury
accounts money in that type of account
is derived from corporate business
activities such as the sale of goods and
services or the sale of corporate stock
it is generally accepted that a
corporation's ability to amass such
funds reflects its business Acumen but
not popular support or even the support
of shareholders for its political views
and they actually cite yet another case
uh which I won't go go to the metal
level of citing yet another case um the
other potential Source the the court
report uh
continues of corporate political
contributions is quote segregated
account typically segregated accounts
are funded by contributions solicited
from corporate officers directors
employees and shareholders these
accounts also represent corporate money
but money that does reflect some degree
of popular support for the corporation's
political goals and ideas so in other
words um the court case in 1999 the
Supreme Court was saying um while we
support the idea that Corporation can
give donations through a segregated fund
where the Monies to that fund come
specifically from donations for
political purposes something we know now
as a pack um the idea that we had had
longstanding and long-standing law that
in general corporations shouldn't donate
from their general fund they supported
the problem was the language was overly
broad weirdly when New Hampshire uh put
a ban on unions uh making political
contributions they did make that
distinction they said that from the
general fund which is what do Do's
paying members pay unions cannot make
any contributions but if they have a
separate fund known as a pack whereby
members donate specifically for that
political purpose then that is okay so
in 1999 the Supreme Court actually when
they struck this down they said and this
is again in the report there is of
course a simple solution to this simple
problem the general court can easily and
effectively amend the statute to reflect
its actual constitutional intent so the
court made it really clear that they
were only striking down the idea of it
of its inability a corporation's
inability to donate from it a segregated
fund but that if we simply got more
specific in the law and made a
distinction between segregated funds and
general funds then in fact that
longstanding law and in fact the the law
of the land on the Federal level would
be completely constitutional
unfortunately um the legislature simply
removed the entire segment referring to
corporations and what that did is that
while that distinction is still in place
for unions um and other organizations I
presume uh where by a an organization
can donate from a segregated fund but
not from the general fund They removed
it completely for corporations meaning
any kind of donation from a corporation
in the state of New Hampshire hampire is
okay so all this does is it uses that
same language to make that distinction
um per the Court's suggestion so that
from segregated funds uh corporate
donations are fine as long as it's that
separated fund what we know is a pack
and then General funds that come from as
the uh the Supreme Court said business
Acumen from selling goods and services
where customers are not necessarily
supporting necessarily the political uh
goals of corporation that those
donations would be illegal um as had
been the law of the land for about a 100
years prior and is still the law of the
land on the federal level and with that
um I guess I'll take
questions thank you representative Reed
room representative Hayward thank you
mad chair thank you representative for
question you have spelled out in this uh
two types of
organizations but by only spelling out
specifically two types of
exclude other types of organizations
which are not a business or not a
union thank you so much for the question
my goal in this was not to create new
law my goal was simply to clarify the
law that had been existing up until
1999 and uh and do as the Supreme Court
had suggested to to keep with the
original intent but keep the language
itself specific enough as to be
constitutional so I did not create any
new organization categories that don't
already exist in
law thank
you further questions from committee
members further questions from committee
electronically I'm not seeing any
representative Reed I do have a question
was this your bill HB 1643 last year
does that ring a bell uh I would not be
surprised I don't have the number in my
head as to which bill it was last year
but that that may that sounds like it
could be correct I just wanted to see if
I might refresh your recollection
because I thought you said that this
passed unanimously last year I believe
the bill was HB
1643 and the committee vote was 13-7
does that sound right uh that may very
well be the case Madam chair I don't
believe I said it passed unanimously I
thought it might have been the one one
of my bills there were a few I think
five or six that were on consent and I
thought it might have been one of those
but if I trust the the chair's
recollection on the issue thank you any
further
questions all right seeing none thank
you for testifying and thanks for
signing up like thank you madam chair um
we do have other people signed up to
speak on this is Joseph Bagshaw here
today um I see him and if you
could
um unmute yourself you are with us Mr
batshaw yes I am here you are yes well
thank you for uh this opportunity to
speak in support of HB 465 I'll try to
be very brief the citizens united
decision although it acknowledged that
corporations are not really people uh
nevertheless awarded to corporations uh
the right to spend as much money as they
cared to uh on political campaigns in
other words they could have as much free
speech as they chose to buy
uh but a corporation per se cannot speak
it doesn't have vocal cords it doesn't
have breath it doesn't have hands to
type a memo so who then speaks for the
corporation you hear the voice of a
corporation who is
speaking
shareholders
no it is
the small cluster of men and occasional
women
in the
boardroom and the Executive Suite who
make those decisions for the
corporation but they don't have to spend
their own money because they have the
keys to the treasure chest the
corporations general fund General
treasury whatever it is
called
uh we can in fact create and this is the
desire of HP 465 a separate fund to
which the corporation or the individual
owners
employees friends can
contribute and from which then uh
political activity can emerge
supporting candidates or political
issues uh that is the intent as I
understand it anyway of HP
465 it would give a lot of
people uh who currently have basically
no say in what the corporation
supports some
voice and that in in its entirety is I
think something that we need to support
and we need to have in
place again thank thank you for your
time thank you
Mr are there any members of the
committee here at room who have
questions for Mr Bagshaw representative
Barry uh yes thank you for your
testimony I have a quick question for
you uh you made a point in your hearing
that these corporations are that the
leadership of these corporations are
effectively speaking for let's call
their employees or their shareholders
whatever you want to to make it
basically that the select few you say
men and occasionally few women are
making decisions for the whole body so
unions operate very similar to this uh
should this bill not be amended to
include a ban on unions as well of
course in fact I would say that it
persons okay thank
you any further questions from committee
members
electronically I'm seeing no further
questions either in the committee room
or electronically thank you Mr vsha for
being with us today thank you also with
us today is Olivia zinc for testimony on
this matter um Miss zinc you have been
promoted to join us as a panelist
welcome this
afternoon um good morning good afternoon
chair chairwoman Griffin and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Olivia zinc executive director for open
democracy action and I am a registered
lobbyist of a nonpartisan nonprofit and
I'm um C zooming in here today from my
home in
Franklin um we are very concerned at
open democracy about the transparency of
campaign funds um as representative Reed
told you the court case struck this
piece of the law down in
1999 but the court also told us how to
fix it and this uh Bill House Bill
465 is basically the the court cas's
interpretation on how to fix it um to
representative Barry's question labor
unions are already prohibited in the
statute as well as limited liability
Partnerships are prohibited
contributions so this also adds
corporate corporate treasury um to this
so this is a good idea because one it
was the new H it was the
law um and two we have these
prohibitions on labor unions and on um
corporate
partnership uh or organizations
registered
as as
Partnerships uh in the written testimony
I submitted yesterday um you will see
from an nhpr story of 28 campaign
contributions that over half of the
donations that are um were raised in the
2018 election of state senators um
accounted for by registered lobbyists
these were corporate entities that were
um lobbying on behalf of these laws um
and I did speak to to some of those and
they said oh we would love this
corporate ban um this this ban exists in
24 States I want to give um this
committee an example of where we see New
Hampshire exploiting this corporate
loophole um the New Hampshire Democratic
party takes money from Colorado
corporations Colorado has a ban on their
um
contributions and then they the Colorado
corporations donate to the New Hampshire
Democratic party and the New Hampshire
Democratic party sends that corporate
money back um to Colorado I think they
do probably take a percentage of it um
but I think it's really important that
we do not allow that kind of money
laundering and we close this important
loophole um it's really important that
everyday citizens feel like they can
participate in our political and
campaign system and know that the rules
are rigged and this is a first step in
fixing our campaign Finance system so I
urge you to vote a to pass on House Bill
465 and fix this important loophole and
I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much for your
testimony anybody in the committee room
have
any questions I'm not seeing any anybody
online attending electronically you have
any questions
I'm not seeing any hands raised so so
thank you for your testimony and do I
understand thank you for your testimony
Miss
mayor yes last week I was appointed the
mayor of Franklin but that's a different
hat it it's a very different hat and I
remember when you ran for Town counselor
so so congratulations thank you I think
good
luck all right is that is all I have
signed up for uh speaking on
465 is there anybody else attending who
matter I'm not seeing anybody's hands
raised so I'm going to close the hearing
on
465 our next hearing on
482 is relative to the use of campaign
contribution
for personal use
expenditures um I have signed up to
speak on this bill the the prime sponsor
and one other person uh representative
bur burough welcome to the committee
this
afternoon and I'm waiting for you to
appear on my screen and you are there
okay can you hear me yes we're all set
welcome awesome thank you good to hear
your voice um Madam share um and thank
you for having me here to testify today
for the record I'm state representative
Anita Burrows and I represent Bartlett
Jackson and Harts location um this bill
um came before the municipal committee
uh last year um my my my recollection is
it went through it passed 17 to3 and was
one of the bills way laid um because of
the covid crisis um the purpose of this
bill um is to better clarify what we
have a murky line that exists between
personal and political campaign
expenditures and I'm not going to read
my testimony but I think and I think we
have seen some abuse in the past of um
of from both sides of the party of
people using campaign expenditures for
personal items such as for flowers for
birthdays funerals and office gifts auto
repairs um com Chamber of Commerce
memberships dry Clan
gas unrelated to a campaign and uh there
was a contribution to the governor's
inauguration and I think that the reason
that this is troublesome is that um I'm
sure many of us have contributions in
our own campaigns of 10 to $2 or more
and these are these are this is money
from hardworking people who have who
specifically are donating money for the
purpose of a candidate getting elected
they did not intend that money to be
used utilized for personal expenses and
I I think the root cause of this problem
is the fact that um New Hampshire uh
state legislators are pay so paid so
little but the answer is not to abuse
campaign um expenditures in my opinion
um that's a different issue uh I have an
exp I live two hours away 4H hour round
trip I knew when I signed up that I
would have Hotel expenses um my husband
and I agreed that that was something we
would incur and um I do not expect my
constituents to pay for that hotel room
um after an election so um um the real
law as it is written now is does not it
does not define uh what what a personal
expense is um and federal law states
that uses the
um uses oh what is it uses the
irrespective test which is is a good
test which says a personal use is any
use of funds in a in the campaign
account of a campaign to fill a
commitment um that would exist
irrespective of a candidate's campaign
or responsibilities as an office holder
but our state law does not delineate
what a personal uh what a personal
expense is now I know that there was um
in the last time around in Municipal
there was some concern about what some
people categorize as the laundry list of
things that that this law would cover um
I if the committee would be more
comfortable in categorizing those
expenses um in a certain way I would be
comfortable with that um um because I
think it's just important that we just
basically set a limit on what the
expenditures can and cannot be used for
um this particular law was based on a
law set in Utah um which they also
delineate the um the authorized and
prohibited use of campaign funds um
other states have chosen to to do
individual things like um Louisiana um
says that you cannot repay personal
contributions or loans um Hawaii says
that um you can't donate excessive funds
um for charitable or scholarship P
purposes before an election date um I
think it's just you know however this is
done I just think it's important that we
make clear to legislators what what they
can and can't do for with this money so
um I guess I will stop there and I will
answer any questions thank
you thank you representative McDonald
thank you madam chairman and good
afternoon representative buros um I was
just curious as to what prompted this is
did a constituent or a donor reach out
to you or is it something that that you
just found troubling and you decided to
do this through your own perspective um
I actually became no it was not a
constituent I became aware of this issue
when I was running for office for the
first time in 2018 there was actually an
actually an article act the article
might have come out in
2017 um about campaign Finance
expenditures and it concerned me um I
actually then went through the uh uh I I
did a random search of campaign
expenditure reports from both sides of
the aisle and the examples I gave um in
in my testimony are actual items that I
found list
so people were reporting on these things
um but they you know were were they were
reporting on them they weren't trying to
hide them but I think I found them to be
Troublesome um in terms of what the
intended use of the contributions were
and um so that that was the um that was
the origin of it thank you thank you
questions representative Sweeney thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative beerus for the question
your legislation in includes a list of
of prohibited items but it's not limited
to um including uh the first one is rent
utilities um meal expenses uh would you
believe that some campaigns for for
state senate executive Council Governor
that are governed by these laws uh pay
rent and utilities for campaign offices
and and have meal expenses for staffers
that are on those campaigns and would
that all be affected by your proposed
legislation
um I I I think your Point's well taken
and it um I think the point the um the
the if the if the language isn't clear
it can be tightened up the purpose of
this that these are not personal
expenses that are used just for um an
individual um I uh it is not it is not
meant to um to interfere with paying
expenditures thank you questions from
electronically I'm not seeing
any thank you representative burough for
your testimony this morning thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
representative
Smith representative Smith you are you
hold on representative Smith I need to
find you I think you're with us as
somebody find me representative Smith oh
there representative Smith I apologize
for taking a minute to find you I see
your hand and now I am doing my push
button thing so welcome representative
Smith to election law this afternoon I
think you are all set to speak if you
unmute
thank you so much um Madam chair um I am
delighted to appear before your
committee
again um and it's strongly in support of
this measure representative Burrows um
as a as a first termer did some
incredibly sophisticated research and
worked very hard uh on this bill and
then as was the fate of so many bills
last term um it um it disappeared um
having been attacked by the virus it's
back now and I think quite healthy and
something that I believe is very much in
keeping with how New Hampshire goes
about um conducting our
elections uh we uh require people uh to
um list their um uh the money that comes
in uh and that g that gives them a lot
of flexibility as long as they do that
it's just as we're allowed to vote on so
many issues as long as we declare in
advance what the conflict is but this is
a way that the legislature can honor um
its institutional commitment to the
citizens of the state and in making sure
that when citizens who are people make
contributions to a political campaign
the money is used for that purpose I'm
sorry that I could not um hear which
member of the committee asked a question
of Representative Burrows um at the end
of her testimony but in I'd like to
respond
a little further to that question um on
uh the first page line 20 it says no
expenditure or use of a contribution
tangible or intangible shall be made for
a purpose that primarily furthers a
personal interest of a candidate or
officeholder or a candidates or office
holders family which interest is not
connected with the performance of an
activity um and then it goes on and
that's where it lists mortgage rents and
utilities so if the uh payment for rent
or utility is for the campaign then that
is a perfectly appropriate expenditure
it is not appropriate if it is being
used um to substitute money that had
been contributed to the campaign for the
personal benefit of the candidate so I I
think that um a careful reading of the
language uh would show that uh
representative Burrow's draft addresses
that very question and I um hope that
you will see this as a way to
better um honor our obligations to the
citizens of the state without in any
inappropriate way restricting the
freedom of the candidate and I urge you
to support um this bill and I am pleased
to be a
co-sponsor um thank you very much Madam
chair thank you representative Smith are
there any questions for representative
Smith
electronically I'm not seeing any
questions thank you very much for being
with us this afternoon thank you it's my
pleasure that concludes hearing from
people who have signed up to speak is
there anybody else in attendance at this
hearing this afternoon who would like to
speak in regards to HB 482 relative to
contributions in campaigns for personal
uses I'm not seeing anybody signed up so
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill for each
to HB 489 is scheduled for
145 um I am opening the public hearing
on excuse me
489 is the bill priting certain
political
contributions the sponsor for this bill
is is representative
Schultz um
and representative Schultz I think you
might already be a panelist I don't see
[Music]
correct there you are thank you very
much for raising your hand I am having a
problem seeing things apparently
today so representative Schulz thank you
for joining us welcome thank you madam
chair and members of the election law
committee it's an honor to be here with
you today to introduce HB
um just want to outline at the
outset what the real purpose of this uh
or the intention behind this bill is
because just seeing the $10,000 limit
isn't uh enough
information um under current law if one
is say a governor of a state and decides
to say run for US senate or congress
there is a law forbidding a transfer of
that money from a state campaign to a
new federal pack uh Campaign Committee
to then use for the election to federal
office
um unfortunately there is no limit on a
war
chest uh from State funds to the state
party apparatus and it's a backdoor way
that gets around the intention of the
federal law to allow an existing War
chest at the state level to be used to
State parties for running for federal
office um I have a a problem with that
and that's the intention of this bill is
that we should be Dr
with our laws to not allow State funds
to be used by the party to allow then
promotion of a candidate to a federal
office
[Music]
um uh that's the essence of the bill um
being able to transfer this money I
think gives an undue advantage in
federal elections I'm also not naive to
the composition of this committee
perhaps if this sitting Governor were
say a former Governor Shaheen or former
Governor Hassen who then perhaps were
running for US Senate maybe the chances
for this would be better um so I'm not
naive but I do think that um it
shouldn't be allowed regardless of party
to be able to take a hefty War chest and
use it for your purposes of running just
under the moniker
of the nhdp or
nhgop um so there's the reason for the
bill it does allow some transfer it
doesn't forbid it uh it just limits it
and I think that is a fair
approach and I think it is a reasonable
solution that brings our state laws um
into alignment with the purpose of what
the federal law says one can do with the
state War chess for federal office
directly uh that's the bill I couldn't
make it any more complicated than
that okay thank you representative
Schultz I I don't know what the
prospects are but you shouldn't be so
dismal the election law just had a
unanimous vote on something so yay great
happen this this turn questions for
representative Schulz from committee
online representative Schultz can I just
ask a question so does this presume that
a party segregates the funds that it
takes in that's a great question I'm
actually happen to be the former um
executive director of the New Hampshire
Democratic party myself uh as far as I
know there there are no efforts
to um there may be separate accounts
that the parties may use for various
purposes but I am not aware of any
specific
divisions set aside to specify for
federal elections on that on that level
so that's that is a good question and a
good
this would prohibit the transfer even if
the candidate from whom the war chest is
being used from transferring the money
even if they had no intention nor ever
correct and I believe that is also the
federal
law that and I'll double check but I'm
pretty sure that that is also a federal
law um um if one is closing an account
because they're not pursuing
reelection okay thank you any followup
questions or further questions from Comm
committee members in the room or
attending
electronically I'm seeing none so thank
you representative Schultz for being
with us here this afternoon thank you
ma'am thank you for your
time um we do have a number of people in
attendance on this bill does anybody in
attendance want to provide their
testimony or opinion um as to HB 489
prohibiting certain political
contributions please raise your
hand I'm not seeing anything so thank
you everybody I'm going to close the
public hearing on 489 with five minutes
to spare before HB
you
great it is 2 o'clock this is the
election law committee the scheduled
hearing at 2 o'clock is HB 468 relative
to the definition of a political
advocacy organization the prime sponsor
on this bill is representative Lane of
our own committee representative Lane
welcome thank
you um for the record I am
representative Connie Lane and I
represent the voters of marac 12 which
is war two in
conquer um HB 468 is a campaign finance
bill that lowers the current threshold
for filing a disclosure from
$5,000 to2
$500 and clarifies what type of
communication qualifies for disclosure
those of us who've been on the committee
it looks very
familiar I'll go through that in a
minute the goal is to make the
expenditures by political uh committees
more transparent um whether they
advocate for an an issue or for a
candidate uh it is virtually identical
to SB 106 which was passed unanimously
by the Senate
in 2019 and then passed this committee
unanimously it passed by Voice vote in
the Full House that year uh but then was
vetoed by governor cunu and was not
overridden the bill also passed um last
year uh in this committee and uh passed
the house by roll call vote
unfortunately when it went over to the
Senate it got caught up in all the covid
stuff and it was tabled so being
persistent
uh we filed it once again hoping that
this time uh we'll get it passed and uh
the governor will agree with us that it
is important for transparency in
campaign
finance and uh with that um I'll take
any questions but I know that there'll
be some speakers who can probably answer
them a little bit better than I and um
that's
you are there any questions for
all right I I we're gonna move on to the
next speaker then I think thank you
um Senator Rubin is also signed up to
bill welcome you are with us if you
unmute I think we will be all
set unmuted and welcome back to election
law yes thank you for having me again I
won't reintroduce myself extensively
except to say that I'm here representing
American promise on Whose board I sit
and take back our Republic which is the
nation's leading conservative campaign
reform
organization and I urge this committee
to uh pass this bill with an aut toass
recommendation but I have a minor
suggestion as to uh adjusting the
language in the last sentence uh before
I get to that uh reasons for supporting
this this basically would help close a
loophole another loophole in the
transparency of our state laws with
respect to campaign financing it's a
good thing a very good principle
according to most conservatives that
voters know where the money comes from
it reduces uh perception of corruption
reduces potential corruption and uh more
information is generally better in
government than less information
and there is a loophole here and it it
can be used to game methods by which
money is inserted into campaigns and so
anytime you have a law where you can
game the system by taking a dollar and
moving it from place a or route conduit
a to conduit B in order to alter
reporting and information to uh to to
the public that that type of loophole
that that can be gamed should be closed
uh in order to make things simpler and
clearer
uh as to the last sentence there I'll
just read it it it says in this
paragraph expenditures do not include
expense expenses for candidate forums
including but not limited to spending
for advertisements marketing or event
expenses I I see that sentence as a
former legislator as being a place where
there'd be ambiguity unclarity and again
the potential for
gaming for reporting so again I hope
urge the committee to uh
uh suggest this bill as ought to pass
and thank you for your time members of
the committee and Madam
Rubin from committee
online I'm not seeing any so thank you
very much um Joe
Hannon has also signed up to speak on
this bill Mr Hannon if you're here could
hand anybody see Mr Hannon I'm not
seeing Mr Hannah no I don't see him
either
okay Olivia zinc has signed up to speak
good afternoon um chairwoman Griffin and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Olivia zinc and I'm the
executive director of open democracy and
nonpartisan nonprofit in conquered and I
am here to speak on behalf of of
supporting aop pass on this important
disclosure bill um it's really important
that voters know who's making political
speech and that everyone who is spending
money to influence New Hampshire's laws
uh vote New Hampshire's elections
register and
Report um this bill creates transparency
when it comes to independent
expenditures and electioneering
communication um I and EC's most people
think of those those as pack spending
but independent expenditures are
political campaign contributions that
expressly advocate for the defeat of a
candidate um or a clearly identified
candidate and this bill strikes the
words functionally equivalent to express
advocacy which are are words that are in
the federal um campaign rules and really
makes it a very important clarification
that if you name a candidate and you are
mailing to people in that District
within 60 days of an election that you
must register and and report this does
not stop anyone from making political
contributions or or making political
speech it just requires them to register
and Report with the Secretary of State
just like any other packs
and um groups do we have collected mail
over the years and seen groups on the
left and on the right who have um use
this
loophole to um not register and report
and it's it's important that voters have
that transparency for an electoral
process to be open and fair it must um
be known and and we need to know who is
uh trying to influence our
elections with that I'm happy to take
any questions about the background on
this bill um I have been working on
disclosure
legislation I think since 2012 here in
New New Hampshire um and so happy to to
answer any questions if anyone is
concerned about disclosure
rules questions from committee members
in the
online Miss zinc I'm I'm going to ask a
question because I know you're very
familiar with this legislation we heard
a couple of bills this morning talking
about campaign expenditures where the
argument has been these limits were set
a long time time ago we need to get with
the times for cost so they're proposing
increasing of limits or amounts this
actually proposes decrease by a large
amount by half 5,000 to
2500 the amount that would trigger this
requirement to register um could you
explain to me what the logic would be in
decreasing the
amount um so original proposed by
Senator Bradley was the $5,000 amount in
his um legislation on
20224 when um Senate Bill 106 was being
negotiated there was a committee
Amendment um by the senate election law
committee which I believe was a 5-0
committee that they thought that in
decreasing that threshold um to
$2,500 I think in if I was spending so
this this would require me if I
said Barbara Griffin loves to ride
horses and I sent out this beautiful
piece of mail right before the election
that you're such a great person because
you love to ride horses to go toown
voters as a you know I wouldn't use
those magic words vote for or vote
against but if you're spending money
with a clearly named candidate within
that narrow period of time um because
it's in that narrow period of 60 days
prior to the election they decrease that
threshold because
$2,500 can go a long way in a small race
um I get that in the gorial race
spending $2,500 on digital ads might not
have an A A same effect as it would on a
house race but I think that's the
committee's prerogative if the committee
does not want to strike that language
it's it is your bill in your in your
hands and if you want to keep the $5,000
threshold but then um close the
loophole to ensure that anyone spending
money to register and
report that is that is that your
committee's
job thank
you any other questions representative
toosan thank you Madame chair thank you
Madame mayor
so if I read this correctly then if the
distribution is made outside of 60 days
the five the $2,500 amount doesn't apply
then correct if you if you if you spent
money right now
um with a clearly identified candidate
um that does not count this is really
trying to get at electioneering
communication within the window before
an election thank you further questions
from committee
members present or online I'm not seeing
anybody thank you
mayor the
next person we have signed up to speak
Moore and he is with us and unmuted good
Moore
rejoining now he's back can you hear me
now yeah you're back now thank you
welcome okay okay I don't know what
happened there we're all working through
some new technology uh for the record my
name is Greg Moore and I am the state
director for Americans for Prosperity
here in New Hampshire I'm here today to
testify in opposition to House Bill
468 uh the there are four reasons
fundamentally why we oppose this
legislation the first of which is the
obvious uh constitutional defect that
would likely mean that this legislation
were to pass would not be enforced by
the Department of Justice uh I earlier
today I sent to the members of the
committee a uh letter from then attorney
general McDonald to then Senate
President Donna suusi relative to
another section of of RSA
664 and however the the con
constitutional issues that were raised
in that letter apply just as equally to
this piece of legislation I'd encourage
you to read uh particularly page two uh
as the department of Department of
Justice rights the uh the uh any as it
relates to first amend First Amendment
protections and and I do appreciate by
the way the members of the committee
texting me to let me know that I'm that
that I was lost for a second thank you
guys uh and and ladies uh I want to I I
want to point out that uh that in the
letter the Department of Justice clearly
writes that uh anything that that
requires disclosure needs to be in their
words well tailored and uh the
definition of entities or organizations
as they state in a letter to uh to sen
former Senate President Susi are not
well tailored meaning that they're over
Brad and uh and fundamentally they they
identify that as one and then they also
view uh these these broad definitions as
not not in Conformity of the due process
clause of the Constitution uh so I think
we could all agree that and I'd
encourage everyone to read the letter
that I sent to the committee uh I think
we can all agree that that passing laws
that won't be enforced really is of no
value and so what I I would strongly
encourage the committee to reach out to
the Department of Justice and ask if
they similarly would not intend to
enforce this legislation due to
constitutional defects so that would be
the first issue that I I think is most
critical and obviously represents a huge
component as as to whether or not this
bill makes any sense
whatsoever secondar secondarily uh there
were two rulings by the uh Department of
Justice in April of 2019 relative to
complaints filed uh against plan Planned
Parenthood that really clarified a lot
of the rules regarding potential
electioneering Communications and one of
the things we saw in the 2020 cycle was
a near absolute uh absolute um use of of
uh moving towards Express advocacy by by
a number of groups as a result of the
clarifications from from those election
election law complaints that came out in
April of 2019 so uh in in the second
instance I would say that as a result of
that I I think that this legislation is
probably a solution in SE of a problem
given the fact that I think that now
that we have that guidance from the
Attorney General's office I think you'll
see organizations use express advocacy
uh the third third issue and this is
real a real problem is that it makes an
assumption this bill makes an assumption
that any
Communications within 60 days of a
primary or 60 days or a general are
designed to be an electioneer in
Communications however we know that
that's not the case we know that there
are things that happen at the state
level of government within 60 days of a
primary or 60 days of a General those
things include veto override votes those
things include uh nominations and
contracts that come before the executive
Council those things include back in
2018 a special session relative to the
Wayfair decision these are all important
issues that that organizations and and
entities might want to opine on relative
to the importance uh to themselves their
and their community so the broad
assumption that any any activity that
mentions the name of a candidate within
60 days of a primary or 60 days of a
general is automatically an election
year in communication is an overb
assumption and then the fourth big issue
is is what this would impact outside of
the the public realm so for example if
Market Basket were opening a new store
and they had a ribbon cutting that
happened to include the governor state
legislators and they put that photo on
their flyer then they likely would have
to register or they would have to
register were this bill to become law
and be enforced they would have to
register as a political advocacy
organization because they would have
used the likeness of of a candidate for
office and spent money behind that so I
I don't think anyone has any intention
of including including something like
that in this in this type of uh law and
and frankly uh as the Attorney General
points out in in in that letter uh the
average person wouldn't understand that
and that's where the violation of the
due process clause comes into place and
then just two other things just to
respond to some of the uh things that
were said earlier I would say that uh
there was a comment that this has no no
this has an impact on independent
expenditures in in fact this has no
impact on independent expenditures uh
groups doing independent expenditures OB
already have to already have to uh file
receipts and expenditures if you want to
see an example that just check Americans
for Prosperity in the in the in the
campaign Finance system you will see
numerous independent expenditures
included in in there so those are
already covered and then and then uh the
last point is is that is that this
legislation uh was was told that was
going to find a way to become make more
transparent election and Communications
and as I said given the fact that there
are other things that take place within
state government over the Arc of over
the Arc of the 60 days before a primary
and 60 days before a general that is an
assumption that is is too broad and I
would encourage of the committee for all
those reasons all these reasons to find
this bill an expedient to legislate and
I'd be happy to take any
questions questions from committee
online Mr Moore I I have a question in
the past in this
discussion we have heard the issue of
Publications being made by Town
officials in regards to elections or say
League of Women Voters who reports to
put out
informational um information certainly
usually within 60 days of an election um
do you think that the definition that's
being used here
66423 would Encompass those I don't
think I've heard anybody talk about
those kind of things uh certainly the
the the the way this this uh bill is
drafted it is is uh intentionally
designed to catch a very very wide net U
which which is what leads to the
Constitutional defect of not being well
tailored and and fundamentally uh a
voter guide or something like that if
you spent $2,500 to mail out a voter
guide across across the state or across
the district or in districts various
districts across the state and that
included so much as one instance of the
use of the name of a candidate then that
organization would then therefore
automatically have to file as a
political advocacy
organization thank you for the
questions I'm not seeing any thank you
Mr Moore for attending this
afternoon thank you and and I would
encourage you to please read through the
letter uh from the attorney general to
uh Senate President Susi thank you I did
see that come in but I have not had a
chance to read it so thank you um signed
up to talk this afternoon was Mr Hannon
he was not there but he is here now and
us uh hello thank you for for listening
to me today my name is Joe Hannah I'm
the vice president for gun owners of New
Hampshire uh having some technical
difficulties here I've been dropped a
few times so um I did hear uh the
previous uh uh person's testimony and
that does save a lot of time for us cuz
he repeated pretty much almost
everything I wanted to say uh I do think
it's it's um it's very difficult to have
blackout periods for uh educating the
public on issues that are important to
different organizations that may or may
not be political advocacy organizations
just because it's a primary season uh or
general election season uh like uh the
previous uh testimon testifier said you
know there are issues that come up
within those periods that have nothing
to do with those general elections and
um the the bar is is lowering the bar is
only hurting some of these smaller
nonprofits and organizations that are
not necessarily political advoc advocacy
groups that would fall into that
category so I I strongly urge you to to
itl HB 468 thank
you thank you any questions from Mr
Hannon from anybody in committee members
electronically I'm not seeing any thank
you Mr Hannon for joining us is there
anybody else in attendance at the
meeting this afternoon who would like to
speak I see Senator Rubin has added his
hands to come back and with the ease of
the electronics welcome
that thank you for having me back and uh
forgive me for neglecting to add this
little bit to the
testimony uh and a little tiny bit of
rebuttal here uh this bill is not a
blackout it doesn't doesn't prevent
anyone from communicating if you're
going to spend more than $2,500 in that
60-day window it just increases
transparency voters can know what's
going
on uh but what I wanted to add because I
categorized this bill as closing uh some
of the dark money loophole and this is
National Data we I don't have good data
on New Hampshire but in the 2020
elections um this this dark money
question has become very partisan with
conservatives opposing increased
transparency and and people on the left
and Democrats supporting it and that may
be historical artifact of the fact that
Republicans used to be better at getting
harnessing and using this money in 2020
dark money nationally uh Republicans
were outspent two to one by democrats in
the could you define dark money for us
as you proceed please money that is
spent to influence the outcome of
Elections or policy matter Ms or
resolutions isn't that any political
spending money that is uh spent but the
source of the money is not disclosed so
you see the money happening the voters
can see there there is money being spent
to influence your thinking about a
particular candidate or
measure uh but you don't know where the
money is coming from that's that's dark
money in general so I just I want to
point out because this issue this matter
has become Wicked partisan that the the
Republicans have got gotten really badly
behind the curve since 2018 it began in
2018 Republicans used to be ahead we're
behind now in the Biden uh Trump
election that just happened in November
dark money for Biden six to one greater
than dark money for Trump so so in
general Democrats and the left have
gotten a lot better at this technique
than people on the right so I don't want
the issue to be pardon partisan but but
in the past I have a theory that people
on the right have supported restricted
transparency as a result of Republicans
potentially being better at harnessing
harvesting and using dark money that's
no longer the case this this matter
should not be partisan at all I'll I'll
conclude there thank you Mr
hin thank you for humoring my questions
during your testimony does anybody have
any further questions for Senator Rubin
I'm not seeing anybody thanks for
staying with us and coming
back is there anybody else in attendance
this afternoon for the hearing on 468
who would like to be heard please raise
your
hand that wasn't your hand I'm not
seeing anybody so I'm going to close the
268 um thank you everybody I believe
that it concludes our business this
afternoon does anybody have any other
business they'd like to bring before the
adjourn I'm not seeing anything so uh we
will see each other next
Friday and uh so all committee members
are aware for planning purposes uh we
have noticed a hearing next Friday the
12th and we will also be meeting the
next week on Wednesday the
17th then it is expected that we will be
having session the following week
Wednesday and
Thursday that's not in stone but that is
the expectation the 23rd and 24th or
24th and 25th I can't remember exactly
what um my My Hope was that I that the
committee would have the first week in
March
off um but maybe I'll have some
discussions with representative Cody
about the schedule because we still have
quite a few bills to exec and if I look
at them organizationally we have a full
day if not more I think of testimony on
bills related to absentee
ballots um and then another full day of
testimony on bills related
to uh forms and registration and same
day voting
so I we need to try and get all of that
worked in for testimony and voting in
time for crossover so um more I should
be able to have a better idea of letting
you know more of what I'm hoping to
schedule to be in March next week so put
on your calendar write down next Friday